Danke fürs Zusch!
Ist jetzt nicht so ganz wirklich das Thema, aber wir können das mal anecken, wenn man noch Zeit hat.
Es ist auch gefragt worden auf der Wikipedia Mitmachseite für Chaosradio. Da hat es auch jemand gefragt. Kommen wir, wenn wir Zeit haben später. Wir wollen uns jetzt erstmal mit den Sachen beschäftigen, die bei mir auf der Festplatte liegen.
Wir reduzieren uns auf das Kerngeschäft.
Also auf Franks Festplatte.
Erzähl doch mal Frank.
Was liegt denn bei dir alles auf der Festplatte?
Sag ich nicht.
Lässt doch mal was vor.
Hast du was zu verbergen?
Dann muss ich dich leider in Beugehaft bringen.
Du kommst zu milden in den Keller.
Ein äußerst übler Scherz im Irrgerall zum Thema Beugehaft.
Bitte.
Nein, den kann ich nicht bringen. Das ist nicht politisch korrekt.
Lassen Sie mich gerade etwas mit Böcken zu tun?
Naja, es ging um einen ehemaligen Bundeskanzler und äh...
Ach so.
Ich versuche gerade, mir den Witz zusammenzuspinnen, aber es ist...
Der Chat scrollt so schnell, ich kann es auch nicht finden.
Naja, so von wegen betreffende Personen können sich ja gar nicht mehr beugen in der Zeit.
Ach so, wegen des Spiegeleierbauches. Das ist was ich hab. Ich kann meine Eier nur sehen, wenn ich... Könnt ihr jetzt mal irgendjemand irgendwas über Verschlüsselung erzählen, damit ihr wisst, ob andere Situationen gerettet werden?
Wir wollen eigentlich jetzt mal grundsätzlich erklären, wie das funktioniert. Komm, wir lassen ihn noch ein bisschen zappeln.
Wir kriegen ganz roten Kopf.
Ja genau, schaut doch mal auf die Webcam.
Ja genau, schaut doch mal auf die Webcam, was ist denn das eigentlich für ein Kabel, das da hinten nicht in der Webcam steckt, frage ich mich gerade.
Das ist das Netzkabel der Webcam, die kann also gar nicht gehen.
Das ist eine WLAN-Webcam.
Okay, wie funktioniert es grundsätzlich, wenn ich...
Nee, jetzt will ich nicht mehr.
Ach moin.
Wie funktioniert es grundsätzlich, wenn ich meine Festplatte, wenn ich Daten auf meiner Festplatte verschlüsseln will? Was, also wollen die die einzelnen Sachen für die Betriebssysteme, unsere Lieblingsverschlüsselungsgeschichten wollen wir noch vorstellen später, aber die haben eigentlich im Wesentlichen alle was gemeinsam.
Ach, ich?
Notfalls kann ich auch noch was überwunden.
Nein, nein, das ist ja alles gar kein Problem.
Für mich schon.
Also, die haben alles gemeinsam, ja. Prinzipiell geht es eben darum, dass man sowas wie eine Art virtuelles Laufwerk, virtuelle Festplatte, virtuellen Datensäge erstellt. Das heißt, das ist sozusagen wie eine weitere Festplatte, CD, sonst irgendwas. Nur, dass die gar nicht physisch existiert, sondern die einfach ausgedrückt wird durch eine Datei auf der echten Festplatte. Also ich hab eine Datei und in dieser Datei ist eine virtuelle neue Festplatte drin. Und alles, was in dieser Festplatte liegt, ist dann verschlüsselt. Und wenn ich das zum ersten Mal öffnen möchte, dann muss ich eben entsprechend das Passwort eingeben, das ich beim Erstellen dieser virtuellen Festplatte in Anführungszeichen eingegeben hab.
Und die virtuelle Festplatte kann auch meine gesamte Festplatte sein. Also das wird dann einmal drüber gestülpt.
Also da gibt's noch so ein paar Einschränkungen, wenn es auch die Festplatte ist, wo das Betriebssystem selbst da ist. Weil du musstest ja davon starten. Also sozusagen kannst du das Betriebssystem selbst nicht verschlüsseln, weil das Betriebssystem muss ja erst mal laufen, damit es entschlüsselt werden kann. Und wenn das Betriebssystem schon verschlüsselt ist, bevor es gestartet ist, dann ist das natürlich schwierig.
Das geht dann in die einzelnen Betriebssysteme hinein, ab welcher Stelle man da verschlüsseln kann. Aber der gängigere Fall ist halt, dass man seine Datenpartition oder seinen Homeverzeichnis oder wie auch immer das unter den jeweiligen Systemen heißt, dass man die eben verschlüsselt. Und da ist dann dieses Konzept des verschlüsselten Disk Images, wie man das dann nennt, sehr gängig und auf allen Systemen verfügbar.
Ich denke, ein kleiner Nachteil dabei ist, dass man sich bei den meisten Programmen vorher überlegen muss, wie viel verschlüsselten Bereich will ich eigentlich haben. Weil ich muss ja erstmal diese verschlüsselte Festplatte anlegen, dieser Datei, und die muss in der Regel eine bestimmte Größe erstmal haben, oder eine feste Größe. Also wir haben uns auch bei der Vorbereitung unterhalten, welche Möglichkeiten es gibt, die möglicherweise auch wachsen zu lassen. Aber der übliche Weg ist einfach, ich lege fest, zum Beispiel ich will jetzt 200 Megabyte auf meiner Festplatte verschlüsselt haben, oder ich will den Bereich haben für 200 Megabyte von meinen Daten, wo ich verschlüsselte Daten ablegen will. So, dann lege ich eine Datei an. Die ist erstmal 200 Megabyte groß. Und diese Datei wird dann von dieser Verschlüsselungssoftware oder von den Betriebssystemen quasi wie ein Laufwerk, nennen wir es V, wie verschlüsselt, wer aus der Windows Welt kommt. Das ist also ein Laufwerksbuchstaben, denn. Und das benutze ich dann ganz normal wie ein Laufwerk. Oder eben auch wird unter den Unix Betriebssystemen wird sie dann gemountet. Das heißt, ich habe dann also irgendwo im Verzeichnisbaum, denn steht mir dieser verschlüsselte Bereich zur Verfügung.
Ja, beim Mac vor allem, da kommen wir dann noch drauf auf die einzelnen Produkte und Lösungen, gibt es auch eine Möglichkeit, das zu umgehen. Unter Linux gibt es einen etwas komplizierteren, mehr oder weniger Weg, mit dem man so halbwegs eine Vergrößerware, ein vergrößerwaren verschlüsseltes Laufwerk schaffen kann. Aber das ist natürlich prinzipiell schon ein Manko des Verfahrens. Ein anderes Problem, was vor allem bei Windows-Software meines Erachtens nach besteht, ist, dass man häufig, also ich möchte zum Beispiel meine E-Mails darauf ablegen. Und wer weiß denn schon jetzt als Standard-Windows-Anwender, wo liegen denn eigentlich meine E-Mails auf der Festplatte, wenn ich die herunterlade?
Interessante Frage.
Und vor allem bei den meisten Programmen ist es halt eine Einstellung, wenn ich die überhaupt treffen kann, die ich bei der Installation mal treffe. Wenn ich jetzt nachträglich sagen möchte, ich möchte jetzt meine E-Mails irgendwie auf so ein Krypto-Laufwerk draufschieben, dann gehen die Probleme schon an. Also das ist alles nicht so straightforward, wie man sich das wünschen würde.
Ja, Chaosradio 111, Chaosradio gibt's immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Wir haben mittlerweile das Bill Lumberg Soundboard gefunden. Gut, damit Huckel auch was zu tun hat heute Abend. Wo waren wir eigentlich stehengeblieben?
Wir waren bei Verschlüsselung und wie mache ich das eigentlich und was haben eigentlich alle diese Programme gemeinsam und wie funktioniert das überhaupt prinzipiell? Wir haben gesagt, es wird also ein Container, so genannter Container angelegt, der verschlüsselt wird und dieser Container wird dann ein quasi wie ein virtuelles Laufwerk auf meinem Computer.
Ist von der Größe des Containers abhängig, wie schnell oder wie langsam mein Rechner arbeitet? Also muss der das jeweils neu entschlüsseln und rechnet sich dabei tot? Oder wie stelle ich mir das vor?
Also mit der Verschlüsselung, das ist auch noch eine Kleinigkeit, die dazukommt. Bei aktuellen Rechnern spielt es aber praktisch keine Rolle mehr. Es dauert natürlich auch ein bisschen länger, der Zugriff da drauf, aber das ist, also wer jetzt nicht gerade irgendwie HDTV-Filme da abspielen will, wo also eine große Datenrate gebraucht wird, dann wird es wahrscheinlich keine Rolle spielen.
Also als Laufzeit, also als, wie man sagt, Wall Clock-Time, also als echte Zeit wird man das nicht irgendwie merken als Anwender. Es ist einfach so, dass die Prozessor-Auslastung deutlich höher ist durch die Verschlüsselung, aber in der Realität, also sozusagen es braucht genauso viele oder wenig Sekunden. Durch die höhere Prozessor-Auslastung habe ich natürlich irgendwie ein bisschen mehr Stromverbrauch und das macht sich dann insbesondere bei Notebooks schon bemerkbar.
Wenn ihr einen Router habt oder einen Fileserver, der noch einen langsam alten Pentium mit 600 MHz hat und ihr wollt eure MP3-Sammlung von einer Festplatte auf die andere verschlüsselte Festplatte kopieren, dann wird er ganz schön warm dabei.
Also es ist schon, es braucht Performance, aber bei gängigen Computern heute muss man sich da nicht wirklich ernsthaft Gedanken drüber machen. Es ist auch so, dass bei den, ich bin da so ein bisschen damit befasst, mit vielen so Network-Attached-Storage-Geräten, also Festplatten, die man ans Netz anschließen kann, irgendwie mit Ethernet oder WLAN. Und da geht es jetzt auch schon los, dass die Hersteller dort sogar Hardware-Verschlüsselungssupport mit einbauen. Das heißt selbst auf solchen, wie soll ich sagen, Sub-50-Euro-Geräten, die irgendwie, wo man noch eine Festplatte reinsteckt, fängt es jetzt an, dass man da ordentliche Geschwindigkeit durch Hardware-Verschlüsselung irgendwie bekommt.
Wir haben ein paar Anfragen gekriegt. Wenn man so eine Verschlüsselung einrichtet, dann fragt mich meistens die Software, welches Verschlüsselungssystem wir zu verwenden. Da gibt es dann meistens mehrere zur Auswahl. Jetzt wollen die Leute natürlich wissen, welches ist davon besonders sicher, welches nicht.
Frank, welches davon ist denn eigentlich besonders sicher und welches nicht? Das ist gefühlter Journalismus.
Es ist schwierig. Generell gibt es ein paar, die jetzt besonders bekannt sind, die sehr populär sind, wo auch viele Leute draufgeguckt haben, die auch relativ einfach sind. Wenn der Algorithmus, also das Verfahren zur Verschlüsselung, einfach ist, dann ist es natürlich auch wesentlich weniger fehleranfällig, behaupte ich mal. Das heißt, je komplizierter so ein Verschlüsselungssystem ist, desto mehr Fehler bei der Programmierung können sich einschleichen. Also grundsätzlich, um ein paar Begriffe zu nennen, AIS, Triple Desk, dürften da keine Probleme machen.
Zum Beispiel, was haben wir noch?
Also es gibt einfach verschiedene. Bei den Sachen, die wir vorstellen werden, kann man auf jeden Fall AIS verwenden, was nach einem derzeitigen Stand, für mich nicht so weit aus dem Fenster lehnen, aber zumindestens für die nächsten paar Jahre sollte das eigentlich Sicherheit geben.
Also es ist eben so, worüber hier sprechen die AIS und dergleichen, das sind Algorithmen. Das ist jetzt also sozusagen das mathematische Verfahren, mit dem die Daten dann letztendlich verschlüsselt werden. Es gibt bei so einem System oder bei einer Verschlüsselungslösung immer eine ganze Reihe von Komponenten. Es gibt einmal eben den Algorithmus, das ist so das Herzstück des Ganzen. Der sollte natürlich hinreichend sicher sein. Das ist dann immer die Frage, wem glaubt man, dass es hinreichend sicher ist. AIS wird eben mittlerweile international als Standardverschlüsselungsalgorithmus in diesem Bereich eingesetzt. Auch in anderen Bereichen, wo es um verschlüsselte Netzwerke geht, VPNs und so ist AIS gängig. Auch bei Schnurrloss Netzwerken findet man immer mehr AIS. Das also tatsächlich bewährt und wird in vielen Bereichen eingesetzt. Neben dem Algorithmus gibt es dann noch einen anderen Parameter, der mit reinspielt, die sogenannte Schlüssellänge, die bestimmt im Wesentlichen, wie lange es denn brauchen würde, wenn jemand alle Kombinationen durchprobieren würde. Also wenn ich jetzt einen Zahlen, man kann sich mal das vorstellen wie mit einem Zahlenschloss. Wenn ich einen Zahlenschloss mit drei Rädchen habe, die von 0 bis 9 gehen, dann kann ich das natürlich schneller durchprobieren, als wenn ich irgendwie eins mit 4 oder 5 Rädchen habe. Und so ist es dann eben auch bei den Schlüssellängen. Je länger dieser Schlüssel wird, umso länger braucht auch man dann letztendlich die Durchprobiermöglichkeiten dieses Schlüssels.
Also AES oder IS? Anton Emil Siegfried.
Advanced Encryption Steam oder so.
Also AES so lang wie möglich.
Na ja, gängigerweise hat man da 128 bis 256 Bit im Moment.
Und 256 ist wahrscheinlich eher die Paranoid-Variante. Genau, die ich nenne. 128, echt ein bisschen einfacher, kürzer, schneller.
Also auf der Apple-Seite zu der Seite File Vault, da werben sie mit Jahr, Millionen, die es dauern könnte, diesen AES.
Wenn das händisch von allen Chinesen gleichzeitig gemacht wird, sozusagen.
Genau.
Gut, aber grundsätzlich geht natürlich auch da, also die Frage ist, vor wem will ich eigentlich die Daten schützen? Wenn es darum geht, dass jetzt ein Dieb, der mein Laptop klaut, nicht meine privaten Daten lesen kann, dann ist da natürlich ein anderer Aufwand noch mal gefragt, als die Polizei, die jetzt wirklich das Interesse hat und ein halbes Jahr meinen Rechner von Experten begutachten lässt oder wenn wir möglicherweise mit irgendwelchen Geheimdiensten zu tun haben, die irgendwelche Unternehmen Daten, Unternehmensdaten von irgendwelchen klauten Laptops holen.
Ja, aber was ist für mich, also wenn ich in der Anwendung, ist doch die Schlüssellänge für mich eigentlich unerheblich. Also ich kann auch, oder ist ein 256-Bit-Schlüssel, also ist der aufwendiger für mich einzutippen?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, das ist nicht mit der Länge des Passworts irgendwie zu verwechseln, sondern es ist die Schlüssellänge und die bestimmt auch wieviel der Rechner rechnen muss, um was ver- oder entschlüsseln zu müssen. Das heißt, ein 256-bit-Schlüssel, da muss dann mehr gerechnet werden als bei einem 128-bit-Schlüssel. Und das heißt also, in der Regel sozusagen die Frage, was nehme ich da, wenn ich überhaupt die Wahl habe bei einem Produkt, dann ist das mehr oder weniger so eine Security gegenüber Performance-Trade-off. Will ich mehr Sicherheit oder ist mir die Geschwindigkeit, also wenn mir die Geschwindigkeit egal ist, dann kann ich lieber ein bisschen längeren Schlüssel nehmen. Wenn es wichtig ist, dass ich hohe Geschwindigkeit habe, dann nehme ich lieber die etwas moderatere Schlüssellänge. Aber weil wir gerade schon beim Passwort waren, das ist ein anderer Parameter, der natürlich immer mit reinspielt, ist, wir sprachen jetzt von Verschlüsselungsverfahren und von Schlüsseln selber. Ich meine, was habe ich da für einen Schlüssel? Ich habe jetzt hier keinen Schlüssel an meinem Schlüsselbund, den ich irgendwie in den Rechner stecke, sondern es geht also hier um ja auch Schlüssel in Form von Daten. Und diese Schlüssel, mit denen die Rechner arbeiten, die sind jetzt nicht mehr für einen Menschen irgendwie leicht merkbar. Also wenn ich jetzt irgendwie so ein 128 oder 256 Bit langen Wert mir irgendwie merken wollte, das ist also nicht irgendwie, also in Zahlen, das ist nicht mehr so wirklich irgendwie beherrschbar. Deswegen macht man üblicherweise bei den Standardprogrammen für einen Heimbedarf ein Passwort in Wortform und von diesem Wort, also irgendwas, was ich eingebe, ein Passwort, manchmal auch als Passphrase bezeichnet, weil das symbolisieren soll, dass es möglichst lang sein soll, damit die Sicherheit erhöht wird. Und davon leite ich dann diesen Zahlenwert ab, der letztendlich als Schlüssel verwendet wird. Und es gibt natürlich auch andere Verfahren, wo man mit Smartcards oder mit irgendwelchen USB-Tokens nennt man die dann, also so wie ein USB-Stick, den man reinsteckt, auf dem der Schlüssel gespeichert ist und so weiter. Aber das sind dann doch eher die professionellen Geschichten und nicht das, was der Heimuser...
Wobei, was natürlich gern gemacht wird auch ist, dass die Programme bieten es in der Regel an, dass ich den Schlüssel sozusagen nicht als Passwort, als Passphrase eingebe, sondern auch als Dateibereitstelle. Und diese Datei kann natürlich tatsächlich auf dem USB-Stick sein oder wie zum Beispiel, was wir am Anfang hatten, auf einem Telefon, den per Bluetooth übertragen werden oder so Sachen. Das ist eine Variante. Das Problem ist natürlich, wenn mir die Tasche mit meinem Laptop geklaut wird, dann ist der USB-Stick weg. Und wenn die Polizei bei mir die Wohnung durchsucht, dann ist natürlich der...
Titankette um den Hals.
Liegt der USB-Stick oder steckt noch im Rechner, dann ist er natürlich auch mit weg. Also das ist nur ein bedingter Schutz.
Kann ich meinen USB-Stick bitte behalten? Da ist alles... die Firmaarbeit drauf, wissen Sie?
Wer dann da noch weiter irgendwie...
Aber kann ich den USB-Stick dann auch noch verschlüsseln?
Jaja, das wollte ich gerade sagen. Wer also da dann noch weiter machen will, da wird natürlich das sowieso dann verschlüsselt. Aber dann geht es auch in Richtung Multifactor Authentication nennt man das dann. Also dass man ein Passwort und einen USB-Stick und vielleicht noch irgendeine komische Zahl aus einer Tabelle, so was wie eine Tandeliste oder so was eingeben muss.
Und einen Fingerabdruck. Einen von den gefälschten Fond.
Das kann man dann auf die Spitze treiben. Aber in richtig Hochsicherheitsanwendungen da hat man dann so eine Mehrfaktor-Authentisierung.
Ihr seid eingeladen anzurufen und genau darum telefonieren wir jetzt auch vor den Nachrichten. Nehmen wir noch einen ran und nach den Nachrichten telefonieren wir weiter. Chaosradio 111 und unsere Nummer ist die 0331 70 97 110. Jens aus Steglitz. Wir hatten vorhin einen Anrufer, der gefragt hat, wie ist es denn eigentlich mit der Beweislast von teilentschlüsselten Dokumenten meiner Festplatte? Darauf beziehst du dich, glaube ich.
Ja, genau. Also ich glaube, er hat doch ein bisschen unverständlich formuliert. Ich habe die Frage. Nichtsdestotrotz, mich interessiert das ja auch. Also jetzt gesetzt den Fall, die haben jetzt Daten eben von mir beschlagnahmt, sage ich mal. Die sind verschlüsselt und die werden entschlüsselt von den Behörden. Wollen wir mal so was drücken, ohne dass ich jetzt mein Passwort preisgegeben habe. Wie ist denn da jetzt, sind die denn überhaupt beweiskräftig, diese entschlüsselten Daten, falls sie es dann entschlüsselt geschafft haben? Weil wenn ich jetzt nur mal an die nicht elektronische Welt denke, ich glaube, ich zu wissen, wenn jetzt zum Beispiel Post oder Brief irgendwie oder Beweismittel nicht rechtmäßig erworben wurden, dann sind die nicht vor Gericht zugelassen als Beweismittel.
Die Frage mit dem rechtmäßig erworben, das war ja auch das, wo die Richterin vor das Bundesverfassungsgericht gegangen ist, da hat gesagt, die sind eben nicht rechts, oder sie sind rechtswidrig erworben worden sozusagen. In dem Moment, dass bei meiner Richterin, also bei ihr, und das war ja auch der Grund, warum die Klage für den Fall, dass sie damit durchgekommen ist, weil es eben nicht verhältnismäßig war. Das heißt also prinzipiell ginge das zwar, aber sie als Richter hätte in diesem konkreten Fall eben nicht durchsucht werden dürfen. Aber das hat jetzt nichts mit der Verschlüsselung zu tun. Letztendlich, wenn die Verschlüsselung geknackt war, Passwort zu kurz, warum auch immer, Pech gehabt.
Sofern das dir zuzuordnen ist natürlich. Ja gut, also wenn es...
Dann kann ja jeder kommen und sagen, wir haben den Schlüssel und das sind die Daten.
Das wäre die nächste Frage.
Ja gut, aber dann muss natürlich das gesamte Rechtssystem in Deutschland in Frage stellen. Das ist natürlich ein anderes Thema.
Und total kann man fast alles in Frage stellen. So lange man nicht gerade Richterin ist, sind das dann auch Beweismittel?
Ja, bei der Richterin waren es auch Beweismittel.
Ja gut, das ist richtig. Als Journalist zum Beispiel Rechtsanwalt, als möglicherweise bist du dann auch geschützt, wobei das halt auch wieder ganz schwierig ist auf einen konkreten Einzelfall. Dann warst du sozusagen in Berufsausübung oder so. Also kannst du dich im Zweifelsfall nicht drauf verlassen. Nee, wenn Daten entschlüsselt werden, Passwort zu kurz, missgebaut, beim Verschlüsseln, was auch immer, Pech gehabt. Backup auf der CD auch ganz beliebt. Backup, die CD ins Regal gelegt, Pech gehabt.
Die CD kann ich dann nicht verschlüsseln, oder?
Das ist übrigens ein ganz großer Vorteil wieder von diesen Containern, diesen virtuellen Laufwerken. Ich kann nämlich einfach diese 200 Megabyte nehmen, auf CD brennen und boop, dann ist sie da verschlüsselt abgelegt.
Ansonsten gibt es auch Backup-Programme, die Verschlüsselung unterstützen. Das ist also im professionellen Bereich eigentlich gängig, sag ich mal. Jetzt beim Heimanwender eher weniger, aber es gibt Software, die das auch unterstützen.
Nach den Nachrichten lassen wir die Katze aus dem Sack, welche Programme sind es?
Genau. Oh, hallo, hier ist Oli Schulz.
Ich prob gerade für den 30.
3.
Abends spiele ich ein Konzert ab 21 Uhr im Knark Club, Davy Van Bolen, die Stimme von Maritime ist auch da. Das wird ein spitzen Abend, kommt doch rum, ich muss weitermachen. Bis dann.
Jetzt präsentiert Oli Schulz live. Abends ab 21 Uhr im Knark-Club Berlin-Prenzlauer Berg. Olli Schulz live und in Farbe. Mit einer großen, dicken Empfehlung.
Und im Radio Fritz. Vom RBB.
Halb 12.
Fritz Info.
Nach drei Wochen Zierverhandlungen haben sich die fünf Veto-Mächte des UN-Sicherheitsrats am Abend auf eine gemeinsame Erklärung zum Atomstreit mit dem Iran geeinigt. Der Text solle möglichst noch im Laufe des Tages von den anderen zehn Mitgliedern des Gremiums verabschiedet werden, sagte der britische UN-Botschafter Perry. In der Erklärung werde der Iran aufgefordert, seine Aktivitäten zur Uran-Anreicherung aufzugeben. In Berlin beraten die Spitzen der großen Koalition seit dem Abend über die geplante Gesundheitsreform. Sie wollen die Ziele der Reform formulieren und den Fahrplan festlegen. An der Runde nehmen unter anderem Bundeskanzlerin Merkel und Vizekanzler Münte Fehring sowie CSU-Chef Stoiber teil. Der SPD-Vorsitzende Platzeck musste wegen eines Hörsturzes absagen. In Frankreich haben die Gewerkschaften zu neuen Protesten aufgerufen. Gestern hat es die größten Demonstrationen und Streiks seit Jahrzehnten gegeben. Sie richten sich gegen die geplante Lockerung des Kündigungsschutzes für junge Arbeitnehmer. Gewerkschaften sowie Schüler- und Studentenverbände wollen am kommenden Dienstag wieder Aktionen durchführen. Bei den Rettungsübungen für die Fußball-WM hat es offenbar massive Probleme gegeben, das berichtet die Frankfurter Allgemeine Zeitung. So sei in der vergangenen Woche die Übung in Berlin abgebrochen worden, weil die Rettungskräfte den Anforderungen nicht gewachsen gewesen seien. Heute Nacht gibt es stellenweise immer mal Regen bei Tiefstwerten zwischen plus 4 und null Grad. Morgen wird es heiter bis wolkig bei Höchstwerten zwischen 11 und 14 Grad. Mit keinen aktuellen Meldungen, überall eine gute Fahrt.
Danke Mario, 2 nach halb 12.
Und wenn im Radio 102, 6, dann Fritz in Berlin.
Chaosradio 111 ist es, was ihr hört. Es geht um Verschlüsselung und zwar Verschlüsselung von Daten und später dann auch noch um die Verschlüsselung von Kommunikation. Chaosradio 111, die Verschlüsselung ist das Thema. Wir hatten vorhin die Frage, ob es denn was nutzen würde oder so ähnlich, wenn wir bei der Fritzbox anklicken, keine neuen Netzwerke zulassen.
Richtig, da hat uns der Batja was geschickt. Die Lösung dazu heißt nämlich, das heißt nicht Netzwerke zulassen, sondern Netzwerkgeräte zulassen und das bedeutet einfach genau, dass die MAC-Adressen von den Geräten, die jetzt im Netzwerk sind, gespeichert werden und keine weiteren zugelassen werden. Ist also diese relativ unsichere Beschränkung, Zugangsbeschränkung, wie sie vorhin gesagt haben, über die MAC-Adressen, bringt nicht so wirklich viel.
Noch eine Frage per Mail. Ist die Passwortabfrage für den Browserzugang auf den Router sicher? V.a. bei Haralds Thema Passwort wären, oder?
Also prinzipiell haben die allermeisten, insbesondere die halbwegs aktuellen von diesen Routern, Hard DPS. Also prinzipiell ist es schon mal gut, dass da eine Verschlüsselung eingesetzt wird. Das große Problem dabei ist nur, und da sind wir wieder bei dem Thema Verschlüsselung und Authentisierung, das große Problem ist, dass wenn ich Verschlüsselung einsetze, dann insbesondere zwischen zwei unterschiedlichen Kommunikationspartnern, dann muss ich auch irgendwie gewährleisten können, dass der andere, der ist der, für den er sich ausgibt. Sonst gibt es nämlich die sogenannten Mail-in-the-Mittel-Attacken. D.h. da steht jemand dazwischen. Ich gebe mein Passwort ein, schicke das zu dem.
der sagt, ich bin der Router.
Genau.
Du kannst es nicht nachprüfen.
Richtig. Das Problem ist nämlich, dass diese Router alle mit einem Zertifikat kommen. Also bei HTTPS gibt es sogenannte Zertifikate. Das sind quasi Signaturen, wo irgendjemand mal bescheinigt, dass dieser Router der Router ist, für den er sich ausgibt. Das Problem ist nur, dass jeder sich so ein Router kaufen kann und auch so ein Zertifikat dann eben irgendwie davon mal runternehmen und die haben ja auch alle das gleiche Zertifikat. Das heißt, es ist ohne Weiteres möglich, da eine Mail in der Mittelattacke zu fahren und dadurch sich zwischen reinzuklinken und das mit abzuhören. Also ohne Weiteres heißt hier wieder, für den versierten mit Netzwerkprotokollen hinreichend detailliert...
Was anderes ist natürlich, es geht ja auch um die Passwortabfrage. Die Mail ist ja auch auf zwei Weisen zu verstehen. Nämlich die Frage ist, ob das Passwort sicher ist. Grundsätzlich ist es so, dass die Geräte mit dem sogenannten Default-Passwort, das heißt also beim Auslieferungszustand haben hier alle das gleiche Passwort.
Eine Freundin von mir rief mich eben an, wir haben uns hier WLAN geholt und irgendwas funktioniert nicht. Gib mal 1-9-2-1-6-8-1-1. Ja, jetzt will der ein Passwort haben. Wir Atmen 1-2-3-4. Ich hab auch gesagt, ne, versuch mal Passwort. Geht nicht. Passwort geht auch nicht. 1-2-3-4. Ne, genau, Atmen, Atmen. Hab ich auch vorher nochmal versucht.
Geht nicht.
1-2-3-4. Und jetzt hält die mich für den Superhack-Sore.
Ja, also es gibt halt maximal, also allerhöchstens vielleicht 10 Kombinationen, die so in der Praxis vorkommen. Also 10% oder 10 Varianten, die bei, sagen wir mal, 95% dieser Geräte vorkommen.
Als wir früher mit den Käfer schlüsseln.
Wobei wir dann auch schon bei der Sicherheit von Passwörtern sind, was auch bei der Festplatten oder E-Mail oder wie auch immer Storage-Verschlüsselung wichtig ist. Ich muss mir ja irgendwie ein Passwort ausdenken für die Verschlüsselung bzw. für die Entschlüsselung der Daten. Und das Passwort sollte natürlich auch irgendwie halbwegs sicher sein. Ja, wenn ich jetzt hier irgendwie den Namen des Herstellers meines Routers eingebe oder irgendwie sowas, dann ist das natürlich irgendwie absolut alles andere als ein sicheres Passwort. Ein sicheres Passwort ist dadurch sicher, dass es nicht leicht erraten werden kann. Es gibt sogenannte Dictionary Attacks gegen Passwörter, wo man einfach ein Art Wörterbuch, nicht nur ein Art, sondern tatsächlich ein Wörterbuch hernimmt, also ein Verzeichnis aller häufig vorkommenden Wörter. Also praktisch eine Dutin. Ja, man kann aber auch sicherlich irgendwie, es gibt auch tatsächlich Firmen, die sowas kommerziell machen. Also es gibt Firmen, bei denen kannst du CD-Images und DVD-Images voll mit Passwort-Dictionaries kaufen. Und die kannst du dann in deinen Passwort-Cracker reinwerfen und der probiert die dann alle durch. Super. Ja, und das funktioniert auch gut. Ich hab das gestern erst wieder getan. Allerdings auch wieder in einem Rahmen. Es ist ein Gerät, das ich selber erworben habe. Und es ist auch wieder so ein Router. In dem Fall ist es ein UMTS-Router. Und da gibt es eben vom Hersteller irgendwie ein Telnet-Zugang. Aber das Passwort wird nicht ausgeliefert. Also Telnet ist so ein Zugang, wo man eben auf untere Ebenen kommt. Also mehr als das Web-Interface. Und das ist zwar vorhanden, aber nicht für den End-User gedacht. Und dann hab ich da mal ein Passwort-Cracker drauf angeworfen. Er soll doch mal diese Passwörter durchprobieren und hat irgendwie zehn Minuten oder so gedauert. Welches war's? Brezis. Das ist der Name einer verteiligten Herstellerfirma. Also ich kenn die. Nochmal. Also was macht ein sicheres Passwort aus? Ein sicheres Passwort macht aus, dass es in keiner dieser komischen Diktionaries drin steht. Das heißt, es sollte kein Wort sein, das irgendwie...
Auch nicht. Ne, Entschuldigung, ich habe irgendwas gemacht. Ich bin nämlich in Wirklichkeit Bill Lamberg. Auch nicht Teile meines Passworts? Also weil es ist so, meine Passworte sind immer ein Sonderzeichen, eine Buchstabenfolge, die ein normales deutsches Wort ist und eine Zahl. Das ist so halb gut.
Na ja, je mehr... Also grundsätzlich sollte da sehr viel Entropie drin sein. Chaos, genau. Du musst Chaos in deinem Passwort sein. In dem Moment, wo du irgendwas, was für den Menschen Sinn ergibt, da drin hast, dann ist das Ordnung und kein Chaos. Und alles, was vom Chaos sinnreichend abweicht, ist also schlechter. Das heißt also, wenn da Worte drin sind, die so existieren, auch abgewanderte Worte, also es gibt ja so dieses Lead Speak, in Anführungszeichen, also wo man dann irgendwie E ist durch Dreier ersetzt und T ist durch Sieben und so weiter. Das kann man natürlich wunderbar auch mit Dictionaries machen. Da muss man halt nur diese ganzen Regeln anwenden und eben statt T sieben schreiben und dann verbiert man das eben durch. Das ist also auch schlecht.
Also eine schöne einfache Methode ist, dass du dir einen Satz überlegst und davon denn zum Beispiel von den Wörtern, jeweils die Anfangsbuchstaben nimmst. Ja, dabei sind auch Zahlen drin, wie meine Oma ist 78 Jahre alt und nimmst du davon Großkleinschreibung, nimmst die Buchstaben, die Anfangsbuchstabung, M, O, I, so weiter und machst daraus dein Passwort. Kannst du dir wunderbar merken?
Ach, dann nehm ich doch lieber Gott.
Ansonsten gibt es eben auch für Leute, die das machen wollen, es gibt Passwortgeneratoren, die also einfach Zufallszahlen so umwandeln, dass Buchstabenfolgen und Zeichenfolgen dabei rauskommen.
Ich glaube es ist gar nicht schwierig, so ein zufälliges Passwort auszudenken.
Bei Mac OS gibt es glaube ich seit Tiger die Möglichkeit überall wo man Passwörter eingeben kann, zum Beispiel für seinen Schlüsselbund, wo man alle Passwörter abspeichert oder eben für andere Sachen. Da gibt es einen Passwortprüfer, der anzeigt wie sicher das jetzt ist. Man kann sich auch Passwörter generieren lassen.
Ist das ein bunter Balken daneben?
Ja genau, der ist von rot bis grün. Und man kann sich auch sagen, ich will ein merkbares Passwort haben und dann noch die Zeichenlänge. Und dann generiert er da eins und zeigt da ihm anhand der Farbe an, wie sicher das jetzt ist. Funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut. Also gerade für die Leute, die gerade sich so rantasten, alles mit Passwortabfrage zu machen, eigentlich ganz gut mal ein gutes Passwort zu kriegen.
Na, Harald, sagst du uns wie bei Linux, lieber Linux?
Ach so, wir sind ja...
Wir sind ja quasi drauf.
Ja, dann nehmen wir doch die, das passt thematisch jetzt besser rein.
Das passt thematisch jetzt besser rein. Hallo Kai.
Deine Verschlüsselungsfrage, Kai.
Ja und zwar, ich beschäftige mich jetzt seit zwei Wochen so mit Verschlüsselung unter Linux und hab da auch was gefunden und zwar habe ich mal noch ein Problem, ob man root verschlüsseln kann.
Ob man was verschlüsseln kann?
Ob man das root System verschlüsseln kann. Also ich kann ja einzelne Partitionen verschlüsseln, aber ich würde ganz gerne auch die root Partitionen verschlüsseln können.
Ja, das geht. Das ist im Prinzip genau das gleiche wie bei den anderen Partitionen. Der einzige Unterschied jetzt so von dem von dem technischen ist, dass beim booten diese sogenannte Init-RD, ich weiß nicht ob dir das was sagt, sind diese Initial-RAM-Disk, in der müssen eben die die Driver und Module für die Verschlüsselung schon drin sein. Also DeviceMapper-Krypto und was du da so brauchst. Und dann müssen die Init-Skripte, also die Systemstart-Skripte, die ausgeführt werden, die müssen eben unterstützen, dass dann ein Passwort-Prompt kommt. Unter Debian zum Beispiel habe ich das auf einigen Systemen am Laufen und das geht standardmäßig. Also man muss gar nichts irgendwie speziell konfigurieren, sondern man verschlüsselt das, man trägt das so in diese ETCFS-Tab ein, in die Liste der gemounteten Fallsysteme und dann kommt automatisch dieses Prompt nach dem Passphrase, wenn man den Rechner hochfährt. Ja, wie das die einzelnen Distributionen machen, die anderen weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Ja, ich benutze Debian, deswegen ist das nicht ganz praktisch.
Da findest du bestimmt auch, wenn du googlest, Leute, die das geschrieben haben.
Ja, ich hab zwar das gefunden, aber da wird der Schlüssel halt auf der Festplatte abgelegt. Das nennt sich hier... Die M-Gript.
Die M-Gript. Genau, richtig, ja. Ja, das ist so die... Das ist die gängige Software, mit der man unter Linux-Systemen der letzten zwei, drei Jahre Verschlüsselung macht. Die M-Gript, noch als Erklärung für die anderen Hörer, ist Device Mapper-Griptographie. Also Device Mapper ist sozusagen so ein Tool, mit dem man irgendwie Geräte auf andere Geräte mappen kann. Also sowas wie virtuelle Laufwerke erzeugen und solche Dinge. Und Krypto dann eben die Verschlüsselungsunterstützung dafür. Und dieses LUKS, was du noch angesprochen hast, L-U-K-S, das ist noch so ein System, das die Handhabung von Schlüsseln bei solchen verschlüsselten Images verwendet. Ja, und du kannst den Schlüssel auch noch nachträglich ändern, wenn man nur das Device mit Verkrypto verwendet nicht geht. Das heißt, man ist dann festgelegt.
Ich hab nämlich jetzt angefangen hier den Schlüssel, also ich hab mir mit PGP Schlüssel erzeugen lassen und hab den auf dem USB-Stick kopiert. Jetzt ist die Frage, kann ich denn das System so buten lassen, dass der mit Hilfe dieses Schlüssels diese Partition einhängt und danach den Passwort fragt? Oder kann ich das nur mit diesem Lux-System machen?
Ja, also rein technisch wär das sicherlich schon denkbar, aber ob es jetzt da fertig was gibt dafür, das kann ich dir nicht sagen. Denk ich auch nicht. Wobei PGP halt auch wieder ein bisschen ein anderes Thema ist, da geht es ja auch um asymmetrische Verschlüsselungen und nicht um symmetrische Verschlüsselungen, was man bei Festplatten verwendet, aber wüsste ich jetzt nicht, dass es da fertig was gäbe dafür.
Wobei man kann natürlich auch das, also das ist meine Variante für Linux mit Loop AES, das ist nochmal eine andere Geschichte. Ja, aber ich hab da ein sehr großes Vertrauen in das System, deswegen benutze ich das auch. Es ist mir sehr angenehm. Ja, aber es ist sehr, ja, also ich hab ein gutes Gefühl. Das ist eigentlich der Verschlüsselungssatz.
Das ist mit dem Ausreden übrigens der erste Satz seit ein paar Minuten, den ich verstanden habe, und zwar von Anfang bis Ende.
Aber die Idee ist, dass du natürlich mit PGP oder GNU-PG einen Schlüssel erzeugen kannst und den dann als Krypto-Schlüssel für die Partition benutzen kannst. Und der ist dann durch eine Passphrase gesichert. Das hat den Vorteil, dass du, wenn du die Passphrase ändern willst, du nicht alles neu verschlüsseln musst.
Richtig. Das ist im Prinzip auch das Gleiche, was das Lux selber macht, aber eben nicht mit GPG. Also nicht mit dem GNU-PG. Haben wir deine Frage damit soweit beantwortet, bzw. nicht beantwortet? Ja, also ich denke, es ist immer eine gute Idee, wenn man anfängt, sowas zu machen, das zu nehmen, was es eben fertig gibt, und nicht versuchen, gleich beim ersten Wurf, sozusagen, sich selber irgendwas Ausgefallenes zu basteln, was sonst noch niemand so gemacht und dokumentiert hat.
Na, mit Loop IAS, mit diesem Loop IAS, was jetzt das ältere System noch ist, da bin ich dann irgendwie nicht klargekommen, weil man noch irgendwelche Patches machen musste, und da hab ich dann doch eher die in Krypt genommen, weil jetzt schon ein Kernel drinnen war, das war mir dann lieber.
Richtig. Und wie gesagt, gerade wenn du deine Root-Partition verschlüsseln willst, da gibt's eben die Unterstützung auch gleich in den Inneskripten und so. Das geht dann also ohne viel Handgefrickel.
Und einen haben wir auch noch. Ne, noch einen haben wir auch, so rum. Hallo Alex aus dem Prenzlauer Berg.
Ja, ich hab erstmal noch ne Frage und zwar, also ne Frage, ich nehm TrueCrypt für die Festplatte. Und da gibt es zum Beispiel ne witzige Funktion, dass man zwei Partitionen ineinander machen kann. Und zwar am Anfang war das Problem, wenn der Richter kommt irgendwie, man muss die Daten auspacken, so nach dem Motto. Dann kann man das auspacken, weil die erste, also man muss sich's so vorstellen, die erste Festplatte ist sag ich mal zwei Gigabyte groß und die Daten werden immer gefüllt, das heißt sind immer zwei Gigabyte auf der Festplatte und man kann dann halt eine andere Festplatte noch reinmachen, das sind sag ich mal beliebig viele Daten, 100 Megabyte oder so. Dann macht man die Partition auf und dann befindet sich in dieser Partition, in der ersten, eine versteckte zweite Partition. In die erste Partition packt man halt ein paar Daten rein, weiß ich, unbedarfte Daten, ein paar nackte Frauen oder so. Ein paar nackte Frauen, genau, sowas halt. Und es erscheint halt nicht die zweite Partition, in der dann die wirklich wichtigen Daten sind. Und das ist eigentlich eine relativ elegante Lösung. Ja, das wollte ich noch mal so sagen, der Geschichte. Also es gibt da halt einen kleinen Workaround.
Guter Übergang, TrueCrypt. Das wäre jetzt so meine, sag ich mal, Empfehlung gewesen. Also wir haben auch...
Ich glaube, aber Alex hatte noch eine Frage, da so ein Aussehen, oder?
Ja, genau. Und die zweite Geschichte, das hatte ich auch in Wiki geschrieben. Und zwar habe ich mal das große Gericht gehört, das im PGP, das ist diese Verschlüsselungssoftware, womit man seine E-Mails verschlüsseln kann, dass eine Backdoor drin sein soll, das heißt also ein Zugang sozusagen für die Nachrichtendienste, wenn es aus Amerika exportiert wird. Ist da was dran?
Also es gibt eine Geschichte, deswegen ist es ins Gerede gekommen und es gab diese Möglichkeit, diesen sogenannten S-Crow-Schlüssel, das heißt also die Idee ist, dass man für den Einsatz in Firmen, dem Firmenadministrator oder sagen wir dem Geschäftsführer, was auch immer, noch die Möglichkeit eines zweiten Schlüssels geben wollte, für den Fall, dass der Mitarbeiter vom Auto überfahren wird, der aber auf seinem Computer wichtige Daten hat, dass man die noch quasi wie einen zweiten Schlüssel dazu macht.
Das ist wie ein Master-Schlüssel.
Genau. Das ist aber eine Sache, die war nicht für die Geheimdienste gedacht, sondern eben genau für diesen Unternehmenseinsatz, der dann aber so massiv beschossen worden ist, dass man das glaube ich einfach wieder entfernt. Ich weiß nicht, ob es drin ist, ich glaube den Commercial-Varianten wird es noch als Option. Ich habe mir das PGP auch schon lange nicht mehr angeguckt, ehrlich gesagt. Der Vorteil ist natürlich, wenn man den Quellcode hat und ihn selber übersetzt, dann weißt du, was du hast, dann weißt du, ob alles drin ist oder nicht. Also das ist der Grund, warum ich persönlich jetzt keinen PGP nehme, wobei das natürlich bei Open Source ist immer so ein bisschen, naja, wer guckt sich das tatsächlich an? Ist das jetzt wirklich, wenn ich jetzt das Debian-Paket lade, ist das jetzt wirklich genau das, wo ich den Quellcode einsehen kann? Aber da ist es auch wieder eher so eine gefühlsmäßige Sache, dass ich der GNU-PG eher ein bisschen mehr vertraue.
Und generell Verschlüsselungssoftware, die aus Amerika kommt, die eine bestimmte Bitstärke überschreitet oder so, dass die halt so einen Backzugang hat oder so, daran ist nichts an dem gerücht?
Also das Schöne ist ja bei Software, also das sind alles Sachen, die wir empfehlen, außer jetzt beim Mac, glaube ich, das ist nicht so. Aber zumindestens bei dem, was auch angesprochen ist, das ist TrueCrypt, da ist der Quellcode eben offen und ich kann es mir angucken. Und da gibt es auch keine Beschränkungen in der Code-Länge oder in der Schlüssel-Länge.
Ja, also es ist auch so, dass diese amerikanischen Crypto-Export, wir hatten das Thema ja vorhin schon mal, aber es ist irgendwie dann nicht zu Ende geführt worden. Also ich glaube seit, na ist ja egal, also auf jeden Fall seit ein paar Jahren, ist es so, dass quellenoffene Software prinzipiell eine Ausnahmegenehmigung hat.
Weil es auch vollständig sinnfrei ist, da irgendwas zu beschränken.
Ja, also es ist beschränkt, das zu beschränken, mit anderen Worten. Nicht, dass das Behörden nicht auch mal öfter nicht davon abhalten würde, aber gut.
Ich hab so eine Mythe gehört, irgendwie, dass sie das Buch exportiert haben aus den USA und woanders wieder.
Richtig.
Jaja, und Phil Zimmerman war ja auch mal tatsächlich eingeknastet. Also das ist der Autor von PGP. Das kann man auch schön nachlesen im Netz, wenn man das irgendwie mal.
Also das ist kein Mythos, sondern da ist schon...
Nein, nein, da ist schon viel dran, das war aber...
Mythos ist ein Bier aus Griechenland.
Sehr schön.
Echt?
Das gibt's ja. Und wenn du zu zweit ein Bier trinken gehst, dann bestellt man zwei Mythen. Das find ich toll.
Sehr, sehr mystisch.
Ich glaub...
Schick geworden auf jeden Fall.
Ja, dankeschön. Werden wir weitergeben.
Wie bitte? Frage beantwortet. www.truecrypt.org Echt mit AE. Genau. Da gibt's einen Download-Link. Wir machen ja so eine schöne, einfach mal so eine userorientierte Sendung. Probieren wir mal heute. Das heißt also, wenn ich mir diese Datei runtergeladen hab, dann bekomme ich, wie ich es bei Windows gewohnt bin, so einen Installer, wo ich dann gefragt werde, wo ich das installieren möchte, ob ich dafür Verknüpfungen machen möchte. Dann drücke ich auf install, dann dachte mir, okay, alles geklappt. Und dann geht es darum, diese Container zu erzeugen. Da haben wir ja schon mal drüber gesprochen. Das heißt, ich muss mir dann überlegen, wie groß soll dieser Container sein. Frag nach einem Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus, da wird aber auch was vorgeschlagen. Und ja, dann richte ich das ein, dann muss ich eben diese Passphrase eingeben. Danach geht in dieser Vorgang, dass ich so genannt mounte. Das ist der Begriff dafür, dass heißt also, ein virtuelles Laufwerk wird eingerichtet. Das heißt also, dieser Container, dieses verschlüsselte File, dieses verschlüsselte Datei, dieser Dateikontainer wird dann gemountet. Das ist vielleicht ein wichtiger Begriff, der immer wieder auftaucht bei diesen Verschlüsselungscontainern.
Im Deutschen übersetzt wird, falls sich jemand unter dem Mounten nichts vorstellen kann, das öfter als eingehängt.
Ins Dateisystem so rein.
Eingepflegt.
Eingepflegt, das ist schön.
Richtig. Es gibt dann, wenn ich das TrueCrypt starte, gibt es einen Button Create Volume, heißt das. Und dann geht so ein Wizard auf, wo ich dann sagen kann, ich mach einfach ein Volume. Und dann fragt er mich wohin diese Datei, dieses Container-File abgelegt werden soll. Da kann ich entweder eine Datei auswählen oder ich kann auch eine ganze Festplattenpartition zum Beispiel nehmen oder auch einen USB-Stick. Das gebe ich dann an. Und das heißt, ich denke mir den eins aus, wo es sein soll. Weiter. Und ja, wunderbar. Dann fragt er mich nach der Verschlüsselung. AIS ist hier vorgestellt, wunderbar. Weiter. Und dann sagen wir, das soll zum Beispiel 100 Megabyte groß werden. Und dann fragt er mich nach einem Passwort. Weiter, dann warnt er mich noch, aha, okay, ist das zu kurz, alles klar. Und dann erzeugt er diesen Container. So, und jetzt habt ihr das alles schön gehört. Und wenn ihr euch einen Mitschnitt anhört, dann könnt ihr das schön nach dem Radio klicken.
Mach doch gleich noch einen Screencast dazu. Am besten so ein...
Ich hab schon wieder einen Trend verpasst.
Unsere Mission für heute ist, es soll keine Ausrede mehr geben. Jeder soll wissen, wie man seine Daten verschlüsselt. Und wir wollen das jetzt einfach mal gemacht haben.
Ich kann ja wirklich im Chaosradio Podcast könnte man eigentlich dann wirklich noch so Screencasts anbieten. Stimmt.
Wie damals PPP mit T-Online ohne die T-Online Software. Das sind auch ausgedruckt rumgereicht worden, weil du ja nicht ins Internet gekommen bist. Ohne Super. Das ist die Nacht des letzten Mittwochs im Monat, da gibt es immer das Chaos Radio. Das ist die Sendung, in deren Rahmen das Chaos Radio stattfindet. Chaos Radio 111 ist heute dran und das Thema ist Verschlüsselung, zur Verschlüsselung von Daten und Kommunikation. Jetzt haben wir über Linux gesprochen, wir haben ein bisschen über Windows gesprochen. Das interessiert mich ja alles im feuchten Kericht, denn ich hab'n Mac. Könnte mir mal jemand sagen, wie ich meine Daten schaue.
Ich möchte betonen, dass ich auch ein Mac hab mit Linux.
Diese Ungläubigen.
Nee, Harald, du meldest dich nachher bitte noch mal an der Kasse.
Wir hätten ganz sowieso mal so unser Modellation gehalten.
Das hab ich ja alles gekriegt. Und mir davon ein Raketenauto gekauft.
Ja, also bei Mac sieht es folgendermaßen aus, wenn man das erste Mal seinen Macintosh Computer startet, dann wird einem gesagt, man muss jetzt erstmal seinen Namen eingeben und einen Usernamen aussuchen und wie kann ich eigentlich genau den Namen, dann steht nämlich überall Holger Kleins Computer, wo ändere ich das eigentlich wieder gar nicht, oder? Na, entweder deinen Kurz, ich glaube deinen Kurznamen kannst du nicht ändern, aber deinen richtigen Namen kannst du noch unter Benutzereinstellungen umkonfigurieren. Ja, jedenfalls wirst du eben aufgefordert, ein Passwort einzugeben, um dich einzuloggen. Allerdings ist, glaube ich, dass bei Mac OS genauso wie bei Windows defaultmäßig, also standardmäßig ist die Anmeldung mit Passwort ausgeschaltet. Das heißt, du startest den Rechner und er meldet sich automatisch an, ohne nach diesem Passwort zu fragen. Das sollte man natürlich erstmal einschalten. So und dann gibt es in den Systemeinstellungen den Knopf Sicherheit, wo es allerlei Informationen zum Thema gibt. Unter anderem kann man eben einstellen, dass er nach jedem anmelden oder wenn der Bildschirm schon ausgeht, erstmal nach einem Passwort fragt. Und weiterhin kann man dann eben dieses besagte File Vault einschalten, was eben das Home Directory, sagt man das in Deutsch am besten, damit es jeder versteht, also das Verzeichnis, wo die ganzen Mails, Einstellungen, Dokumente, Bilder, Musik liegen, dass das verschlüsselt sein soll. Und dann sagt man Turn on File Vault und erstellt dann eben so ein mitwachsendes Image, also so eine virtuelle Festplatte sozusagen, kopiert das ganze Home Directory da rein und jedes Mal wenn man den Computer ausmacht, macht er dieses Image, packt er das zusammen und dann liegt nur noch eine Datei auf der Festplatte. Und wenn man den Computer wieder anmacht, dann wird man aufgefordert sein Passwort einzugeben und das Image wird sozusagen entschlüsselt und in das Dateisystem eingepflegt.
Wenn ich das jetzt einschalte, dann legt er dieses Image an, kopiert alles rüber, bleibt dann das Original erhalten und meine Festplatte ist doppelt so voll?
Nee, es ist vollständig an die Stelle von deinem ursprünglichen Homeverzeichnis. Also du als Benutzer merkst auch gar nicht, dass da jetzt irgendwie was im Hintergrund anders ist. Das haben sie eigentlich ziemlich gut integriert. Ja, du hast jetzt bloß statt deinem Haus sozusagen ein Schlosssymbol.
Und mein Passwort bleibt mein Passwort.
Genau, es wird nämlich auch das Passwort, das du am Anfang eingegeben hast, sozusagen dazu verwendet, auch dieses Image zu schützen. Und ja, dementsprechend sollte das Passwort natürlich auch gut gewählt sein und nicht XXX.
Ich muss schnell nach Hause.
Ja, aber abgesehen davon ist das dann ziemlich gut. Und du hast eben auch noch die Möglichkeit bei macOS mit dem Festplatten-Dienstprogramm noch weitere Images zu erstellen. Also wenn du jetzt nicht nur dein Home-Verzeichnis verschlüsseln willst, dann kannst du sagen, ich möchte jetzt ein neues, mitwachsendes Image machen. Und da kannst du dann Dateien reinschmeißen. Und das wächst halt mit, je mehr du reinschmeißt. Und ja, das kannst du dann sozusagen zuschließen und kannst es erst wieder öffnen, wenn du dein Passwort eingegeben hast. Und das kannst du dir dann auch frei aussuchen.
Schrumpft es auch mit?
Genau. Während du eingeloggt bist, schrumpft es nicht, sondern wächst nur. Allerdings, wenn du dich dann ausloggst oder den Computer zumachst, dann guck danach, wie viel Platz wird jetzt verbraucht und wie groß ist das Image. Und optimiert das dann sozusagen, macht es wieder kleiner, wenn es zu viel ungenutzter Platz ist.
Jetzt hab ich schön meinen Mac, hab FileWord aktiviert und das ist alles ganz toll und die Polizei kann da nicht ran. Wer garantiert mir, dass die nicht doch da ran kann, weil da eine Backdoor drin ist?
Das Department of Homeland Security garantiert mir das.
Das Reichssicherheitshauptamt. Wieso garantieren die mir das?
Ja, das ist von denen sozusagen verbrieft oder verbürgt, die sagen, das ist sicher.
Aber entschuldige, das US-amerikanische Department of Homeland Security ist doch gerade bestrebt, meinen Rechner durchzuschnüffeln.
Oder nicht?
So verstehe ich diese Behörde. Die sind doch dazu da rumzuspionieren und nicht zu sagen, hey, wenn du nicht willst, dass wir in deinem Rechner rumschnüffeln, dann benutze das.
Ja, aber das ist auch mit dem RSA-Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus ja genauso. Den benutzen auch extrem viele Leute. Und der ist eben genauso auch von der US-Regierung sozusagen zertifiziert. Und trotzdem haben da eine ganze Menge Leute daran Vertrauen. Ich weiß nicht, ob Harald da vielleicht noch...
Naja, also es ist halt bei den Algorithmen wie auch bei AIS, was wir ja vorhin auch schon empfohlen haben und so, so dass in der Tat diese Algorithmen auch schon wie die Vorgänger DES und so als, wie soll ich sagen, Ausschreibungsergebnisse von amerikanischen Behörden letztendlich ermittelt wurden. Also da werden sogenannte Wettbewerbe veranstaltet und dann können Kryptologen, Kryptographen, können da Beiträge einreichen. Und dann gibt es eben, wie soll ich sagen, wissenschaftliche Panels, die sich das alles anschauen, die das eben beurteilen. Und das, wie soll ich sagen, die Regierung ist da gar nicht so ausschlaggebend. Die Regierung lädt eigentlich nur ein Beiträge von Wissenschaftlern, lässt es dann beurteilen, auch wiederum von namen auf Wissenschaftler.
Zerlegen sich denn gegenseitig die Algorithmen?
Genau, weil jeder will ja, dass seiner besonders gut dasteht. Das heißt, die hacken dann alle gegenseitig irgendwie ihre Sachen klein.
Teilweise ist der Telekom auch mal was sehr Peinliches passiert. Sie haben nämlich einen Algorithmus namens Magenta ins Rennen geschickt. Und es war ein ziemliches Desaster.
Auch die Farbe ist ja auch schon irgendwie fragwürdig.
Da muss man gar nichts kommentieren.
Gibt es irgendwie ein Stichwort, was man sich ergoogeln kann, um da den Scherz zu lesen?
Ich würde sagen irgendwie AIS Competition Telekom Agenta, würde ich übrigens als Google Stichwort da mal so eingeben.
Auch ansonsten ist die Wikipedia natürlich wieder eine beliebte Quelle, um sich mal zu diesem AIS näher zu informieren. Also hier steht halt eben auch drin, dass die NSA ihre eigenen Dokumente damit verschlüsselt und das sozusagen der Vertrauensbeweis ist, dass...
Also grundsätzlich ist es natürlich auf jeden Fall gut, wenn der Quellcode von so einem Verschlüsselungsprogramm offen gelegt ist, weil die Verschlüsselung oder die Sicherheit liegt nicht nur in dem reinen Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus, sondern auch in dem Drumherum. Das ist auch nochmal eine ganz große Schwachstelle. Das heißt also, wenn dieser Schlüssel eingegeben wurde, dann liegt er im Speicher. Und es gibt bei modernen Betriebssystemen, zumindestens bei Windows ist es so, einfach, wenn ich zum Beispiel vom Laptop dem Deckel zuklappe, dann wird der Inhalt des Speichers auf die Festplatte geschrieben. Das heißt also der Rechner schläft dann, Tiefschlaf, Hibernate. Und der Inhalt des Speichers, inklusiv möglicherweise meines Schlüssels, wird dann natürlich unverschlüsselt auf die Festplatte geschrieben, in so einer Tiefschlaf-Battei.
Nicht nur des Schlüssels, sondern auch eben...
Der entschlüsselten Dateien, die gerade offen sind.
Das heißt immer runterfahren.
Ja, immer runterfahren und noch, das ist eine Option, das kennen ziemlich wenig Leute, es gibt eine sogenannte Auslagerungsdatei, Swap Space ist also ein Bereich von einer Festplatte, eine Datei, wo die Sachen hin ausgelagert werden, die nicht mehr in den Arbeitsspeicher passen. Also wenn ich mit großen Dateien hantiere, dann kann da das Betriebssystem nochmal Daten auslagern, eine sogenannte Swap Datei oder Auslagerungsdatei. Und die sollte man beim Runterfahren auch löschen. Das ist ein bisschen versteckt, da muss man mal nach googeln. Aber es gibt die Option bei Windows, das so zu einzuschalten, die Sicherheit einzuschalten, dass diese Auslagerungsdatei nach dem Runterfahren gelöscht wird.
Das Lösen alleine bringt aber nun auch noch wirklich nichts.
Ja, das richtig, da müssen Sie noch von der Festplatte wippen, das heißt noch mal die Bereiche auf der Festplatte, wo es vorher war, auch noch überschreiben.
Die Gaussen.
Nein, um das zu umgehen, möchte man eben Encrypted Swap haben, das ist das, was, ich weiß nicht, wie es da bei Windows aussieht, aber jedenfalls unter den Unix-artigen Betriebssystemen ist das eine gängige Option. Das heißt, dass dieser virtuelle Speicher, dieser Swap Space, auch verschlüsselt wird, unter Linux zum Beispiel mit den gleichen Mechanismen, wie man auch diese Festplattenverschlüsselung macht. Nur, dass man hier keinen Schlüssel vom Anwender vergibt, sondern dass bei jedem Booten ein Zufallszahl als Schlüssel genommen wird. Und dann, wenn der Rechner ausgeschaltet wird, zum Beispiel, weil ihn ein Bedarfsträger gerade aus dem Rack schraubt, dann ist dieser Schlüssel einfach weg. Und beim nächsten Booten wird eine neue Zufallszahl genommen und der Swap Space wird neu initialisiert. Der ist ja auch immer nur gültig für einen während der Laufzeit des Systems. Wenn ich so runterfahre, dann brauch ich das auch nicht mehr.
Genau, bei Mac hatten sie nämlich mal dieses Problem, dass jemand rausgefunden hat, dass in diesen Swap-Dateien noch das Login-Passwort abgespeichert war oder zu finden war, mit dem man sich angemeldet hat. Und daraufhin haben sie dann eben auch diese Checkbox unter Security oder Sicherheit eingeführt, dass man auch seinen Swap Space verschlüsseln kann.
Ich muss dringend nach Hause.
Gerade in diesem Moment dringen sie ein.
Einen dünnen DNS.
Vielleicht gibt's eigentlich, ich höre, benutzt ihr eigentlich Verschlüsselungen? Also ruft uns doch mal an, wenn ihr irgendwie gute oder schlechte Erfahrungen mit solchen Sachen gemacht habt.
Wenn ihr schon mal euer Passwort vergessen habt und nicht mehr an eure gesammelten was auch immer...
Oh, da gibt's irgendwo bei einem Kumpel in Darmstadt noch ein Protokoll aus dem Irk von 19... 1994 oder 1995 muss es gewesen sein. Da kam irgendwie einer in Irk und war noch total besoffen und hat uns darüber informiert. Er meinte, er hätte sein Rootpasswort geändert, als er noch besoffener war und wüsste nicht mehr wohin und ob es denn nicht irgendeine Möglichkeit gäbe, da ranzukommen.
Naja, beim Rootpasswort ist das echt...
Er zählt das bloß nicht weiter, hat er auch dazu geschrieben. Im Januar war der damals 95, mein Gott. Da kannten sich alle Deutschen im Irknet. Im Internet genommen.
Ich kannte dich damals nicht.
Deininger Hobbymigdmann.
Nein! Ich muss mal noch eine Ergänzung zu dem File Vault machen, nämlich... File Vault? Das hat nämlich ein Problem, diese mit wachsenden Images. Der guckt ja immer beim Ausschalten des Computers, wie groß es ist sozusagen. Und korrigiert dann die Größe. Das Problem ist jetzt, wenn man das auf einem Desktop-Computer macht und auf einmal der Strom weg ist und er keine Chance hatte, das Image zuzumachen und zu verschlüsseln, dann ist sozusagen das ganze Home-Verzeichnis möglicherweise einfach weg. Also sie empfehlen für Desktop-Computer eine Notstromversorgung davor zu klemmen, damit das nicht passiert, dass dein Rechner auf einmal ausgeht und dein gesamtes Home-Verzeichnis nutzlos ist.
Da hätte man für Deutschland eine Regelung, hätte keine regellose Regelung. Und die Länder, die das nicht regeln wollen, die haben dann die Bundesregelung. Und die Länder, die das regeln wollen, können dann das für sich regeln.
Ja, wir haben Spaß und unterhalten uns. Und genau darum ist es eine Unterhaltungssendung. Macht bitte was draus, hört raus, Radio 111.
Unterhaltet uns doch mal mit einem anderen Vorurteil.
0331-70-97-110, wie verschlüsselt ihr eigentlich und was für Erfahrungen habt ihr mit eurer Verschlüsselerei? Verschlüsselerei? Verschlüsselerei hätten schon so gemacht. Gute oder schlechte?
Und habt ihr sonst noch Fragen?
Genau, ich werde im Chat schon gerade nach dem Soundboard gefragt. Ich werde mal gerade in den Irk...
Also das Soundboard hier, das ist meine Jingle-Maschine.
Nee, das gute alte...
Nein, nein, nein.
Was hier im Irk auch gesagt wird, ist, äh... Nein, dieser Stäuber...
Stäuber, echt?
Diese Verstäuferung.
Okay, soll ich noch mal zum Mitschneiden machen?
Ja, aber dann bitte die Mikros aus und lachen.
Okay, alle Mikros aus und die Musik auch im Hintergrund. Und Achtung, ähm, Mitschneiden jetzt.
Dann hätte man für Deutschland eine Regelung. Es hätte keine regellose Regelung. Und die Länder, die das nicht regeln wollen, die haben dann die Bundesregierung. Und die Länder, die das regeln wollen, können dann das für sich regeln.
Stäuber-Rules.
Was?
Ich sagte Stäuber-Rules.
Erregeln, ja.
Irgendwo haben wir noch den Transrabit.
Yes, den brauchen wir auch noch.
Alles klar ist. So, wir gehen ans Telefon. 0331 77 97 110. Tino hat angerufen. Hallo Tino. Du hast eine Frage?
Genau zum Netzwerk. Es war jetzt was ganz anderes. Ich hab vorhin irgendwie gesagt, dass das irgendwie alles Quatsch ist. Wenn man jetzt dem Router sagt, er soll seinen Namen nicht hinauspusauen und wenn man sagt, er soll nur festgelegte MAC-Adressen benutzen, hat es mich ein bisschen verunsichert.
Ja, frag mal, wen Sie noch verunsichert haben.
Ich hab das alles so eingestellt, dass er den Namen nicht rauspusauen soll, dass er auf einer verminderten Leistung sendet, dass er nicht überall hinsendet, dass er nur bekannte MAC-Adressen nutzt. Dann hab ich eine WPA2, also ich glaube, das ist diese IIS-Verschlüsselung.
Vor allen Dingen hast du ein Internettelefon, ne?
Richtig.
Merkmal.
Und lädst gerade große Dateien nebenbei runter.
Es macht auf jeden Fall nicht unsicherer, wenn du dein Netz versteckst und die Sendeleistung reduzierst und die MAC-Adressen restriktierst. Also das ist auf jeden Fall schon hilfreich. Es macht es nicht unsicherer.
Letztendlich ist die Verschlüsselung das, was du haben willst.
Genau, und das hat er ja. Also er hat ja gesagt, er hat die Verschlüsselung. Das andere ist dann ja nur noch so optionaler Schnickschnack außen rum.
Also das tut im Prinzip, also wenn man diese IIS-Verschlüsselung hat, das reicht im Prinzip aus. Man muss diese andere gar nicht mitnehmen. Also man könnte jetzt auch, er könnte jetzt auch die Namen ins Netz hinausposaunen.
Das würde im Prinzip nichts machen.
Ja, die, die irgendwie in dein Netz reinwollen, die sehen auch dein Netz, wenn es sich nicht zeigt.
Also Netz verstecken ist dann gut, wenn du hast halt irgendwie, machst deinen Computer auf und hast fünf Netzwerke. So siehst du, fünf Netzwerke. Und ein sechstes ist deins verschlüsseltes. Und die anderen fünf sind alle auch auf. Und wer mal eben schnell Internet braucht, nimmt halt eins von den fünf und nicht ein sechstes unsichtbares. Aber wirkliche Sicherheit bringt es halt nicht so. Und wer halt die Daten haben will, dem ist es auch egal, ob es unsichtbar ist oder nicht.
Also gut ist auf jeden Fall diese WPA oder WPA2-Verschlüsselung, weil damit wird dann das schon sehr verhindert, dass man in deinen Verkehr reinschauen kann und in dein Netzwerk überhaupt reingeladen kann.
Und auch diese Leistungsbegrenzung oder so, bietet das auch noch Sicherheit oder ist das auch?
Na das verhindert... Genau, erstens das und zweitens sehen dann deine Nachbar eine Wand weiter, schon mal das Netzwerk wahrscheinlich nicht mehr. Also du könntest gar nicht erreichen sozusagen.
Wobei, wie gesagt, also das Einzige, was wahrscheinlich 99% der Sicherheitszugewinnens ausmacht, ist die Verschlussfindung und das restliche 1% kannst du dann aufteilen auf die drei anderen Dinge. Die fallen nicht wirklich ins Gewicht.
Und dann habe ich noch mal eine Frage, wie kann man diese Internet-Telefonie, die ich gerade mache, wie kann man denn die verschlüffeln?
Ja, also da gibt es...
Was benutzt du eigentlich, darf ich mal fragen? Welchen Provider? SIP oder Skype? Was benutzt du gerade?
Ich mach das über 1 und 1.
Es bieten tatsächlich auch ein paar Provider, bieten es schon an, ja, secure voice over IP, wo denn die Pakete, die Inhalte verschlüsselt werden. Das hilft natürlich dann tatsächlich auch nur bis dahin, wo sie entschlüsselt werden, mit dem Telefonanbieter. Und es hilft zum Beispiel nicht dagegen, dass die Polizei zu dem Telefonanbieter geht und sagt, macht uns jetzt mal bitte hier den, schneidet mal mit, macht uns den Verkehr auf, den Telefonverkehr. Ja, also es hilft halt dagegen, dass irgendwie der Nachbar mit lauscht. Dagegen würde es wohl helfen.
Aber wenn man jetzt eine Fangschaltung hätte oder so, dagegen würde das nicht helfen, dass man so ein abhörsicheres Telefon hätte.
Nee, ein abhörsicheres Telefon, dafür bräuchte es was anderes. Da gibt es auch Sachen, die dann so eine End-zu-End-Verschlüsselung machen. Das würde denn funktionieren zwischen den beiden Computern. Also ich würde nur ungern Werbung machen für Skype, aber meines Wissens sind da die Pakete auch verschlüsselt untereinander und zwar auch End-zu-End. Korrigier mich, wenn ich das falsch sage.
Wenn das stabil funktionieren würde, dann wäre es ja richtig praktisch.
Skype ist, sage ich mal, ich will jetzt gar nicht zu weit darauf eingehen, aber es gibt Leute, die haben sich das ein bisschen genauer angeschaut und die haben natürlich auch potenzielle Sicherheitslücken gefunden. Und den ganzen Aufwand, den Skype getrieben hat, zu verstecken, wie es funktioniert, der ist jetzt eigentlich dahin. Und es ist zu erwarten, dass sich da noch mehr Leute in Zukunft drauf stürzen werden. Und da wird vielleicht noch was passieren in der Zukunft mit Skype.
Was Gutes oder was Böses?
Also schwarze Hacker oder weiße Hacker?
Always in motion the future is. Jemand hat dem Chat geratet, die URL zu dem Stoiwafire als mp3 gepostet.
Sehr schön. Wie kommen wir da hin zum Chat?
Der Channel Chaosradio auf dem ERK Server irk.freenode.net.
irc.freenode.net Ja, da wird sicherlich auf Nachfrage nochmal der ein oder andere diesen Link posten. Eine Frage zu Passwörtern von Jens aus Frankfurt.
Hi, ich hab eine Frage und zwar ist es denn möglich, wie gesagt, dass da eine spezielle Partition angelegt wird im Funktions- oder Teichfile und es ist ziemlich unwerteilig, dass ich selber meinen Passwort vielleicht 10- oder 20-mal falsch eingebe und dass einfach beim x-mal, sagen wir ein 20-mal, dass dann der Inhalt komplett gelöscht wird.
Das kann man im Prinzip schon so implementieren in einer Software, also man kann Software so programmieren, dass sie das macht, aber das ist eben kein, wie soll ich sagen, das ist Bestandteil dieser Software und wenn jetzt jemand anders zum Beispiel diese Festplatte bei dir Cloud entwendet, Beschlagnahmen, was auch immer, dann kann der einfach andere Software verwenden, die diesen Counter nicht hat, also diesen viel Bedienungszähler, noch viel besser, also in der Regel ist es so, wenn die Polizei dein Rechner beschlagnahmt, dann ist das erste, was sie davon macht, bevor sie ihn einschaltet, ist eine Kopie von der Festplatte machen, also manchmal lässt sie den Rechner auch bei dir und nimmt nur die Kopie mit, ist ja ein glücklicher Fall, so und dann können die einfach 10.000 mal probieren. Ja, also solche Fehlbedienungszähler, die funktionieren eigentlich immer nur dann, wenn sie in Hardware implementiert sind und nicht in Software. Ja, also es gibt ja bei den GSM-SIM-Karten, also bei den FIFÖR-Handys auch, wenn du dreimal die PIN eingibst, dann musst du eben die Super PIN und wenn du da was falsch machst und so weiter und das funktioniert eben nur deswegen zuverlässig, weil das eben in der Hardware dieser SIM-Karte so implementiert ist. Also das kann zwar auch wieder ein Stück Software sein, was da drauf ist, aber es ist niemand kommt an diesen Speicher heran, ohne den Chip aufzumachen. Genau, richtig. Das ist eben der wesentliche Unterschied. Hingegen, wenn das alles nur in der Software auf dem PC ist, dann kann man da einfach andere Software nehmen und damit ist das Ganze dann umgangen. Es ist eine Augenwischerei, wenn es so eine Software was anbietet.
Gute Nacht.
Mir fällt euch gerade noch ein, wir hatten in einer der vorigen Datenschleudern auch einen Artikel, wo jemand so ein wirklich Hardcore-Verschlüsselungs- und Sicherungsvariante seines Rechners mal vorgestellt hat, wo der Rechner dann erstmal guckt, ob er im Internet ist und ob er von der richtigen IP in eine bestimmte Datei fatschen kann und wenn das nicht ist, dann löscht er gleich die ganze Festplatte und im Detail kann ich das jetzt nicht genau ausführen, aber der Artikel war sehr lesenswert. Für die, die da wirklich jetzt sich gegen sämtliche Feinde rüsten wollen, mal ein Datenschleuderarchiv nachblättern.
Es gibt auch Tresore, die man kaufen kann, die man remote innen sprengen kann. Also da stellt man seinen Rechner in so einen massiven Tresor rein und man kann dann, wenn man irgendwie, was weiß ich, das mit dem Typ, mit dem Türschloss oder mit irgendwas verbinden und wenn jemand nicht ordentlich irgendwie authentisiert das beim Tür aufmachen, dann wird ein Sprengsatz im Schrank gezündet und dann ist der Rechner da drin kaputt. Außen merkt man überhaupt nichts.
Das will ich.
Das kostet aber ein paar Mark.
Egal. Hauptsache es macht BUM. Oh Gott, habe ich das gerade gesagt. Noch eine Frage zu Passwortern. Hallo, Janik.
Ich habe eine Frage. Und zwar, was ist eigentlich, wenn mir meine Platte abrauscht?
Dann sind die Daten ohnehin weg. Ob verschlüsselt oder nicht?
Naja, normalerweise kann ich, auf jeden Fall, sofern mir der Schaden verträgt, kann ich normalerweise wieder herstellen.
Die Frage ist sozusagen, ob das schlimmer ist, wenn ein verschlüsselter Container kaputt geht oder wenn ein einzelner Teil kaputt geht.
Also beispielsweise bei TrueCrypt habe ich gesehen, kann man sich den Header sichern. Und da ist jetzt die Frage, wie kann man da die Daten auch wieder herstellen kann. Weil das ist ja vor allem interessant für Leute, die jetzt mal eben nicht nur so viel Gigabyte oder sowas an Daten haben, die sich nicht regelmäßig auf eine DVD brennen können, sondern ein bisschen mehr. Kann man ja nicht regelmäßig sichern. Das ist ja recht unumfraglich, wenn dann auf einmal die Platte weg ist.
Ja, dass Zeitalter in dem ganzen DVDs im Internet geschert werden.
Ja, also das ist tatsächlich ein Szenario. Wenn du zum Beispiel deine 160 Gigabyte Platte voll hast mit NP-30, kommst du nach Hause und stellst fest irgendwie so...
Also das hängt im Wesentlichen davon ab, wie denn tatsächlich das On-Display-Out von diesen, also wie die Daten abgelegt werden von der jeweiligen Verschlüsselungssoftware. Sicherlich, wenn da irgendeine Art von Header ist, dann muss der repliziert werden. Also entweder eine Sicherheitskopie oder man, oder der wird eben schon von der Software mehrfach abgelegt. Das ist eigentlich das gleiche Problem wie schon bei einem normalen Dateisystem. Ja, es ist so, dass Dateisysteme auch so was wie ein Superblock zum Beispiel haben häufig. Und dann wird in dem Dateisystem selber auch schon, ohne dass das irgendein Anwender merken würde, schon mehrere Kopien auf unterschiedlichen Stellen der Platte gehalten.
Ich hab dann ja in der Regel bei dem modernen Dateisystem immer mehrfach vorhanden, die Zuordnung.
Was auf jeden Fall eine gute Strategie ist, dass du diesen Container erstmal entschlüsselst und dann von da versuchst, eine Datenrettung zu machen.
Ja, und was eigentlich die größere Probleme ist bei der Verschlüsselung, ist meines Erachtens eher, dass es zu wenig Programme gibt, die wirklich daukompatibel sind.
Also von meinem Gefühl her, also da gebe ich ja recht, aber von meinem Gefühl so was wie TrueCrypt, denke ich, also das ist ja der Anspruch an die Sendung, die wir eigentlich haben. Also es soll keiner mehr die Ausrede haben, er wusste nicht wie es geht, oder es war zu kompliziert oder so. Deswegen haben wir gesagt, okay, wir gucken uns mal an, was sind wirklich die Sachen, die Lösungen, die möglichst einfach zu bedienen sind und die wir noch, also vom technischen her, mit dem Wissen, was wir haben, noch guten Gewissens empfehlen können, die also ausreichend sicher sind.
Wenn man sich überlegt, dass jetzt gerade erst mal die Postbank überhaupt anfängt, jetzt Mail zu signieren, damit man jetzt nur noch bei signierten Mails seine Pin-Tan-Kombinationen rausgibt, ist es natürlich...
Die gibt man nie raus, auch nicht mal eine signierte Mail.
Ja, das ist klar, aber...
Jetzt denkt er sich gerade, verdammt.
Verdammt.
Jetzt werden die nächsten Fishing-Mails eine Zeile haben, diese Mail ist elektronisch signiert und garantiert für ihre Sicherheit.
Das Problem ist, wenn du dich mit Verschlüsselungen beschäftigen musst oder deine Daten verschlüsseln willst, dann gibt es keinen Weg drumherum, sich ein bisschen damit zu beschäftigen. Das ist leider so. Man muss ein bisschen nachdenken, wenn man seine Daten sicher haben will. Es geht nicht um die Klick- und Los-Gehts-Lösungen.
Ich glaube, das ist genau das Problem, warum das so wenige Leute machen.
Das ist im realen Leben auch so. Wenn du ein sicheres Schloss an der Tür haben willst, dann musst du dich auch ein bisschen mit Schlössern beschäftigen.
Man muss nicht das alte Schloss von Oma.
Sicherheit ist immer ein Kompromiss im Verhältnis zur Bequemlichkeit. Wenn du die Daten sicherer haben willst, dann musst du ein bisschen Abstriche bei der Bequemlichkeit machen. Schon allein, dass du immer noch mal ein extra Passwort eingeben musst. Aber hey, so ist es halt.
Lieber sicher, als ein auf einmal den Bach runtergegangen ist. Okay, ich bedanke mich.
Super.
Gute Nacht, Janik. Ich würde vorschlagen, wir machen Nachrichten, falls unser Nachrichtensprecher ist. Du hast jetzt genau 39 Sekunden Zeit.
Wollte auf der großen Bühne im Tempodrom klingen.
Hello, I'm Adam Green.
Morgen Abend ab 20 Uhr. Im Tempodrom am Anhalter Bahnhof.
Exakt halb eins. Mit Mario Bartsch.
Der UN-Sicherheitsrat hat den Iran aufgefordert, binnen 30 Tagen seine Aktivitäten zur Uran-Anreicherung einzustellen. Eine entsprechende Erklärung verabschiedeten die 15 Mitglieder des höchsten Gremiums der Vereinten Nationen am späten Abend in New York einstimmig. Der Text war in den vergangenen drei Wochen von den 5 UN-Veto-Mächten ausgehandelt worden. Nach fast fünf Stunden ist in Berlin am späten Abend ein Spitzentreffen der Koalition zur geplanten Gesundheitsreform zu Ende gegangen. Ergebnisse wurden zunächst nicht bekannt. Ziel der Beratung ist ein Kompromiss zwischen den beiden Modellen von Union und SPD, der Gesundheitsprämie und der Bürgerversicherung. Im Tarifstreit des öffentlichen Dienstes der Länder hat die Gewerkschaft Verdi den Druck auf die Arbeitgeber verstärkt. Auf einer Großkundgebung in Hannover protestierten 12.000 Beschäftigte gegen längere Arbeitszeiten. Verdi-Chef Zirske forderte die Tarifgemeinschaft der Länder auf, die Verhandlungen wieder aufzunehmen. Im Tarifkonflikt der Klinikärzte bleiben die Fronten verhärtet. Ein Sondierungsgespräch am Nachmittag scheiterte. Die Streiks werden deshalb fortgesetzt. Palästinenser Präsident Abbas hat am Abend in Gaza die neue palästinensische Regierung vereidigt. Sie steht unter der Führung der radikal-islamischen Hamas-Bewegung. Einige Mitglieder des neuen Kabinetts unter Ministerpräsident Hanja mussten ihren Amtzeit im Westjordanland abgeben. Sie hatten von Israel keine Reiseerlaubnis für den Gazastreifen erhalten. Heute Nacht bleibt es meist trocken bei Tiefstwerten zwischen plus 4 und 0 Grad. Am Tag wird es heiter bis wolkig, bei Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 11 und 14 Grad. B 158 Berlin-Angermünde zwischen Kreuzung Blumenberg und Kreuzung Tiefensee. Gibt es in beiden Richtungen Gefahr durch Tiere auf der Fahrbahn. Moment, liegt ein toter Fuchs auf der Fahrbahn. Hier dann guten Appetit. Gute Fahrt ansonsten.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2, dann Fritz in Spremberg.
Mir Selle Chaosradio 111 ist es, was sie hört. Mit knapp einer halben Stunde haben wir noch Zeit und es geht um Verschlüsselung von Daten und natürlich auch Verschlüsselung von Kommunikation. Da haben wir noch gar nicht so viel.
Also wie verschlüsselt man eine Kommunikation? Ist das jetzt so? Nö, wollen wir nicht.
Also das Thema oder Untertitel heißt es ja auch, also Briefe, Datentresore, Briefumschläge und sowas. Also klar, wir wollen sagen, es gibt GNU-PG und ja, es gibt es und es ist gut für E-Mail-Verschlüsselung, benutzt es.
Wie ist es eigentlich mit meinen externen Festplatten? Kann ich die genauso verschlüsseln wie die interne Festplatte in meinem Rechner?
Ja, du kannst da genauso ein encrypted Disk Image, also ein verschlüsseltes Disk Image erstellen und das einfach auf deine externe Festplatte legen und einfach dann da an dieses mitwachsende Image, jetzt auf dein Mac zum Beispiel.
Aber es ist ja, es ist schon gewachsen, also die ist schon voll. Kann ich da was drüber stülpen oder muss ich dann alles erstmal runternehmen und wieder zurückschieben?
Ja, da musst du erst ein bisschen hin und her schieben.
Das ist im Zweifelsfall richtig hässlich Arbeit, ne?
Ja, also ich hab gerade bei jemandem im Club das gemacht, der wollte nämlich auch seine externe Festplatte verschlüsselt haben und der hat aber jetzt gerade eine leere Festplatte. Und da haben wir dann einfach ein Image raufgelegt und das ist kein Problem.
Da sehe ich den Businesszweig des Festplattenverleihs auch kommen. Das muss ich mal eben eine Festplatte leiten, umkoppieren.
Stimmt, gar nicht schlecht.
Das ist auch total praktisch, um an ganz viele MP3s und Filme und Porno-Sammlungen zu kommen.
Lass uns telefonieren. Zum Beispiel mit Thorsten, eine Frage zu Swap-Dateien.
Okay, alle klar. Hallo erstmal.
Wo bist du denn drauf?
Nein, ich war auf der Seite.
Man kann ja Betriebssysteme von CD booten, zum Beispiel Knoppix oder diese Spark.de. Es ist da sichergestellt, dass der Arbeitsspeicher nicht auf die Festplatte ausgelagert wird, also so eine Swap-Datei oder...
Die verwenden in der Regel überhaupt, also solange du als Anwender das nicht anders konfigurierst, verwenden die von sich aus überhaupt nichts auf der Festplatte, diese Live-Distributionen.
Von Knoppix weiß ich, dass man es so einstellen kann, dass es obers macht oder nicht.
Also die grundsätzliche Idee ist ja, dass seine Festplatte nicht angefasst wird und die Dinger funktionieren ja im Prinzip auch ohne Festplatte sogar.
Dann könnte man die, also von CD booten mit Betriebssystem und dann nur die verschlüsselten Dateien auf der Festplatte lassen.
Von welchen verschlüsselten Dateien redest du jetzt?
Na wenn man z.B. mit TrueCrypt eine Datei verschlüsselt, dann könnte man ein Betriebssystem von der CD starten und dann nur die verschlüsselten Dateien von der Festplatte mounten.
Ja, wo ist dann der, also was versprichst du dir dann in dem Fall davon, dass du von CD bootest?
Na dass nichts auf der Festplatte landet. Also ich benutze auch TrueCrypt jetzt unter Windows.
Ich muss kurz erwähnen, es geht auch unter Linux. Das heißt, man kann die Container von beiden Betriebssystemen aus denn lesen, was auch ein Vorteil noch ist für die Leute, die beides benutzen.
Ja und ich hatte noch festgestellt, dass ein Teil der Daten nicht in den Container landen, sondern auch noch im unverschlüsselten Teil. Und deshalb wollte ich halt von einer Live-CD die ganze Boot nennen.
Der Vorteil ist natürlich, wenn du sagst, nimmst du jetzt einfach die ganze Festplatte und verschlüsselst sie, dann kannst du natürlich die Verschlüsselung quasi von der CD starten und dann mit der Festplatte weitermachen. Aber gerade wenn du in Unix, in Linux benutzt, ist es natürlich ganz ganz einfach zu sagen, dass irgendwie alles, was in deinem Home verzeichnet ist, ist dann einfach verschlüsselt und sind dann einfach deine Dateien, deine Mails und weiß nicht was alles. Ja, da kannst du dann zum Beispiel sagen, du machst einen, also das wäre meine Empfehlung, wenn du sagst TrueCrypt, machst du einen Container, formatierst diesen Container, also man muss das auch machen, man muss diese Container denn auch formatieren, die sind sozusagen wie eine leere Festplatte denn, und erzeugst dann ein Dateisystem, zum Beispiel dann FAT32. Das ist ein Dateisystem, was beide Windows und Linux lesen und schreiben können. Mit NTFS geht es nicht. Und dann kannst du diesen Container wunderbar zwischen beiden Betriebssystemen abwechselnd benutzen, lesen und schreiben.
Ja, mach ich ja auch schon so, aber das Problem ist halt bei Windows, da landet halt ein Teil in der Registry oder in der Dateitabelle oder in der Auslagerungsdatei und deshalb wollte ich halt irgendwie mit VARPE oder wie das heißt.
Also wenn du genug Speicher hast, dann kannst du natürlich die Auslagerungsdatei unter Windows auch komplett abschalten. Das geht ja. Du kannst sagen Größe 0, dann wird nichts ausgelagert.
Dann verhält sich das Windows bestimmt super, oder?
Nicht schlimmer als ein Mac mit wenig RAM.
Die Swap Monster.
Und zwar das geht über Systemeigenschaften, also Arbeitsplatz Systemeigenschaften. Und dann, findest du es schon, unter Leistungsoptionen erweitert, la la la, virtuelle Arbeitsspeicher, da kannst du das einsteigen.
Und dieses DM-Crypt, da gibt es das nur für Debian oder auch noch für andere Linux-Distributionen?
DM-Crypt ist Teil vom Kernel. Also das ist ein Mechanismus im Kernel, der generell Block-Devices verschlüsseln kann. Und das ist also in jeder Linux-Distribution vorhanden. Es gibt also da Konfigurationssoftware dazu, aber die ist auch bei allen gängigen Distributionen mitgeliefert.
Okay, wenn ihr noch Sachen habt, Chaosradio at ccc.de, schickt uns das, wir versuchen zu antworten.
Wir versuchen es zumindest. Noch mal eine Frage zu Voice-Over-IP. Roland.
Also ich habe das noch nicht selbst ausprobiert, aber vorhin hatten Anrufer gefragt wegen der Verschlüsselung für Voice-Over-IP. Ich habe glaube ich auf den Webseiten von dem Programm Xlight gelesen, da gibt es auch eine Bezahlversion und die hätte dann Verschlüsselung eingebaut zwischen den beiden Teilnehmern, die das benutzen. War ich da was bekannt?
Na, die Software speziell kenne ich jetzt nicht, aber es ist halt so, es gibt eine Reihe von Standards, auch oder mehr oder weniger Standards, was Verschlüsselung bei Voice-Over-IP betrifft. Aber das ist halt auch wieder ein sehr komplexes Thema. Also die Voice-Over-IP-Protokolle sind an sich sehr viel komplexer und vielfältiger als jetzt bei E-Mail zum Beispiel. Und selbst bei E-Mail muss man ja auch schon unterscheiden zwischen der Transport-Level-Verschlüsselung, zwischen der End-zu-End-Verschlüsselung mit GPG und so weiter. Und bei Voice-Over-IP gibt es jetzt auch unterschiedliche Verfahren. Es gibt also einmal ein Verfahren, das war so glaube ich das erste, was bekannt war, dass man bei SIP die Metadaten mit GPG verschlüsselt, also gemäß dem Open-PGP-Standard. Da sind aber dann die eigentlichen Gesprächsdaten noch nichts unter, also die Sprache. Dann gibt es die Variante, wo man mit TLS, also dem Abkömmling oder dem Nachfolger von SSL arbeitet, sowohl für die Metadaten als auch für die Sprachdaten. Also dass sehr viel Unterschiedliches alleine schon jetzt im Bereich SIP verfügbar und implementiert. Und da ist dann natürlich jedes Programm, hat da andere Optionen, jedes Programm unterstützt irgendwas oder nicht. Manche erfinden irgendwas eigenes, das ist alles noch ein bisschen unübersichtlich und noch nicht sonderlich kompatibel.
Also müssten auf jeden Fall beide Teilnehmer das gleiche Programm verwenden einfach?
Das ist mit Sicherheit immer die beste Variante, ja.
Ich hab mal eine Frage zur rechtlichen Seite der Verschlüsselung. Und zwar, ich hab auch toll alles, irgendwie eine verschlüsselte Partition auf meinen Rechnern. Und irgendwie geht aber immer so das Gerücht um, dass im Falle einer Hausdurchsuchung der Schlüssel rausgerückt werden muss von mir. Die werden mich zwingen, den Schlüssel raus zu rücken. Wisst ihr da was zu?
Hatten wir relativ am Anfang der Sendung schon mal. Also du musst dabei unterscheiden, kein Problem. Also vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz. Du musst unterscheiden, ob du dabei Beschuldigter bist oder Zeuge. Und wenn du Beschuldigter bist, dann musst du schon mal gar nichts sagen und auch überhaupt gar nicht daran mitwirken, dass du dich belastest. Da wird dir im Zweifelsfall auch dein Anwalt weiterhelfen. Aber grundsätzlich ist es so, du sagst nichts, du machst nichts, hast keine Ahnung und überhaupt. Die sollen sich zum Teufel scheren. Das hilft in letzter Konsequenz auch. Was anderes ist, wenn du als Zeuge geladen wirst, dann können sie dich möglicherweise zwingen. Da gibt es irgendwie ein bisschen einen Umweg. Da muss sich aber auf jeden Fall auch ein Anwalt beraten, dass du sagst, naja, ich habe da aber Material auf der Festplatte, was mich selbst belasten würde. Damit würde ich mich selbst beschuldigen in einer Straftat. Zum Beispiel, nennen wir mal Kinderpornografie. Du hast dann halt irgendwelche Fotos da drauf.
Steuerhinterziehung.
Das haben wir ja.
Genau, ist angenehmer.
Deswegen haben sie mich mal drangekriegt. Das ist gar nicht so angenehm.
Das musst du allerdings glaubhaft machen. Das heißt, das darf nicht nur wie eine Ausrede klingen, aber auch da berät ich dir in dem Zweifel 2 deinen Anwalt.
Okay, also letztlich wie ganz normales Aussageverweigerungsrecht.
Richtig.
Ich bin immer da verrückt rum, dass es da irgendwie noch eine spezielle Rechtgebung gibt für den Fall.
Nein, gibt's nicht. Du driftest irgendwie gerade ab. Hast du auch Voice-Over-I-Fee?
Nee, ich hab hier mit Handy gerade.
Ach so, okay. Ich hab hier gerade mit Handy.
Genau, so ist es. Also wie normales Aussageverweigerungsrecht auch.
Dann Kevin aus Wetzlar.
Guten Morgen, Jungs. Alles klar.
Ja, Mahlzeit.
Und selbst.
Ja, bei mir auch. Ich ruf wegen folgenden an und zwar, ihr ist den für Schlüsselung. Gibt es eigentlich irgendwie eine günstige Möglichkeit, also ein Zusatzgerät für ESN-Telefone, für einen ESN-Anschluss zu kaufen, sodass man halt, keine Ahnung, wenn man halt mit einem Freund oft telefoniert, dass man sagt, hier, wir kaufen uns das Ding, oder vielleicht sogar ein einfacher Bauplan, der zusammenzulöten ist, um einfach ESN-Telefonate zu verschlüsseln?
Du hast kein Internet, also kein DSL oder so was, wo du zusätzlich Internet drüber machst. Also das wäre der einfachere Weg, sag ich mal, wenn du eine Software benutzt, die einfach über Internet... Nee, das stimmt schon.
Also es geht mir halt auch darum, ich denke mir, das wird bei vielen auch so sein, dass einfach vielleicht auch nicht immer die Internetverbindung auf beiden Seiten besteht. Ich sag mal, vielleicht ist jemand, ja, an gewissen Stellen, also ein Telefon ist eigentlich immer überall so, ja, überall vor Ort, ja.
Wobei natürlich nochmal ein Unterschied ist zwischen einem ESN-Anschluss, wo du rankommst und einem normalen Telefon.
Okay, nee, ich geh schon mal davon aus...
Taschentuch vor die Sprechmuschel halten.
Ich geh mal schon mal davon aus, dass an beiden halt ein digitaler Telefonanschluss vorhanden ist. Und ich hatte ja ja ein verstorbenes Mitglied vom CCC hatte ja mal so etwas gemacht. Irgendwie ein Bausatz, der...
Ja, seine Diplomarbeit war das.
Genau. Und ja, ich hab davon auch gar nichts mehr gehört, weil ich denk mir, ja, alle haben den ESN-Telefonanschluss und gibt's da irgendwie einfache Möglichkeiten oder günstige Endgeräte?
Also günstige nicht. Es gibt natürlich welche für den Punkt-Gov-Bereich sozusagen, also den Regierungsbereich oder für Behörden, die so was anbieten. Das ist natürlich eine entsprechende Preisklasse.
Nee, das ist ja klar. Dafür gibt's ja eigentlich in allen... Also klar, ich geb dir die Sicherheitsfirmen, die bieten dann 3, 4, 5.000 Euro. Es ist wie alles Sachen, Dinge an. Aber also, kennt ihr irgendwas, wo man hier... Telefon hat jeder, ESN, günstig irgendein Zusatzgerät sich holen kann?
Ja, sorry, ist leider so.
Was natürlich auch eine Variante ist, nimmst du einen Laptop, eine ESDN-Karte und baust dann eine Software drauf, die das verschlüsselt macht, dann...
Ja, also bei Voice-Over-IP sieht es da besser aus, bei ESDN eher weniger. Ich bezweifle auch, dass sich das jetzt groß ändern wird, weil das Renten geht ja eigentlich weg hin. Also für die Power-User, sage ich mal, geht das Renten ja eindeutig hin weg vom ESDN-Anschluss. Wozu braucht man den noch? Also man, für das Paarmal Telefonieren nennt man Voice-Over-IP. Das ist eh günstiger. Irgendwie die Grundgebühr für den ESDN-Anschluss, die kann man sich schon sparen.
Ja, das stimmt. Das Potenzial wird jetzt auf jeden Fall mal größer, was auch schon jetzt unheimlich weit verbreitet ist, aber das ist ja der Zustand mit dieser Verschlüsselung beim ESDN, dass ich da bisher auch wirklich bisher wenig gefunden hab. Die ist ja schon seit einigen Jahren. Und vor einigen Jahren war das Ding mit dem Voice-Over-IP auch noch nicht so der Renner überall. Und ich, ja okay, keine Ahnung woran das jetzt liegt, ja. Vielleicht wollen da paar Leute nicht, dass sich, ja, dass sich damit damals welche beschäftigt haben. Also ich weiß nicht woran es liegt, aber nun gut, wenn ihr sagt, es gibt nichts, jetzt geht's ja eh auf Voice-Over-IP.
Okay, Kevin, gute Nacht.
Jo, euch auch, ciao.
So und jetzt pass auf, jetzt Matze.
Hallo Jäger.
Matze hat eine Metafrage.
Also nicht direkt Metafrage, aber ich bin absoluter Newbie, was Sicherheit angeht. Und zwar ich hab ein Netzwerk zu Hause, unter anderem mit WLAN und es ist ein gemischtes Netzwerk zwischen Windows und Windows PC und 2 Macs. Und ich verschlüssel, das Einzige was verschlüsselt ist, ist praktisch der WLAN Zugang. Und ansonsten nichts. Und ihr hattet eben, ich bin leider zu spät gekommen, ihr hattet eben so ein Thema, wie kann ich mein Mac sicher machen. Ich hab das irgendwie nicht ganz so mitbekommen. Ist das gefährlich, was ich mache, weil ich nicht verschlüssel oder?
Naja, das kommt wieder auf das Bedrohungsszenario an, was du fürchtest. Also wenn du jetzt Angst hast, dass jemand über das Netzwerk, über WLAN sozusagen auf deinen Mac eindringt, ja das besteht jetzt erstmal nicht so, weil du natürlich, also ein Passwort wie gesagt am Anfang beim Installieren deines Macs sitzt und jeder, der dann auf deine Daten zugreifen will, sich ja erstmal auf deinem Computer einloggen muss mit genau diesem Passwort. Und wenn du das nicht kennst, dann kommt da auch erstmal nicht rein.
Über WLAN jedenfalls zu Hause im Heimnetzwerk. Jetzt aber was anderes, wenn ich zum Beispiel einen Router, den hab ich jetzt auch zu Hause, und jemand klingt sich ein und will auf meinen Mac zugreifen, und würde jetzt mein wegen meinen Benutzernamen und mein Kennwort kennen. Bei Windows ist es ja so, dass ich einzelne Ordner freigeben kann. Wenn aber jemand den Benutzernamen und das Kennwort von meinem Mac kennt, der hat voll Zugriff auf meinen kompletten Rechner. Und da gab's mal so ein Programm, das nennt sich SharePoint.
Genau, das gibt's auch immer noch soweit ich weiß.
Genau, ich hab das auch installiert und irgendwie, wenn sich jemand auf meinen Rechner einloggt, der sieht trotzdem alles, obwohl ich SharePoint aktiviert hab und nur einzelne Ordner freigeben kann.
Ja, das ist allerdings wahr, das ist ein bisschen schwierig zu konfigurieren gewesen. Ich brauchte auch jedes Mal, wenn ich da so einen Ordner einrichte, so drei, vier Testläufe, bis es dann so funktioniert, wie ich das haben würde. Ich kann dir da auch gerade keine konkrete Hilfestellung geben, außer eben du kannst natürlich unter MacOS in den Systemeinstellungen auch einfach alle Zugriffe ausmachen. Also es gibt ja Windows-Sharing oder entfernte Anmeldungen, wie es in Deutsch heißt für SSH. Und wenn du da einfach das Häkchen wegmachst, dann gibt es eh sozusagen keinen Weg zu deinem Computer.
Gut, also das heißt, wenn ich dann doch Daten austauschen möchte privat, dann müsste ich praktisch jetzt wieder in die Systemeinstellung gehen, und muss das wieder aktivieren.
USB-Stick.
Ja gut, dann ist aber auch zu... Also in dem Moment, wo du wieder überall eben ein unverschlüsseltes WLAN zum Beispiel Daten austauschst, dann kann natürlich auch jemand mitschneiden. Das ist also auch zu berücksichtigen.
Ja, aber wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel jetzt als Zweifel diese Airport-Steckdosen-Station da habe, die ist ja von Grund auf eigentlich verschlüsselt.
Ja, die hat auf jeden Fall auch dieses WPA als Verschlüsselung.
Genau.
Genau, ja.
Das heißt, da brauch ich mir... Habt ihr denn jetzt für mich als Heim-User irgendeinen Tipp, was ich auf jeden Fall machen sollte, um irgendwelchen Angriffen, oder sei es, wenn jemand an meinen Rechner geht, dass er da nicht rankommt? Holger hat da irgendwas eben gesagt.
Was hab ich gesagt?
Holger hat die ganze Zeit gesagt, auf jeden Fall, er muss jetzt nach Hause und irgendwas machen.
Sein WLAN-Router an sich.
Erstmal das...
Ich muss nach Hause noch ein Fläschchen aufmachen.
Also, ich mein, wir tun uns da mit Empfehlungen schon etwas schwierig. Ich mein, wir haben jetzt in der Sendung ja erst mal beschrieben, was es so für Besuchungsszenarien gibt und wie man sich vielleicht dagegen irgendwie wehren kann. Und sozusagen ohne, dass du uns sagst, gegen was du dich schützen willst, ist es schwierig, eine Antwort zu geben.
Das stimmt. Na gut, dann soll ich mir vielleicht meine Frage konkreter überlegen.
Das wäre...
Schick's einfach nochmal per Mail zur Not.
Chaosradio.ccc.de Schreib ich euch.
Macht matte. Interessante Frage kam von Steffen per Mail. Nämlich gibt's auch MP3-Player, die fand ich auch spannend. Wobei natürlich muss man sagen, dass wir im Moment in Deutschland ja die Situation noch haben, dass ein MP3-Player mit Musik drauf erstmal so kein Problem an sich ist. Weil das ist jetzt eigentlich ein anderes Thema, aber es ist erstmal nicht strafbar, einen MP3-Player mit Musik drauf zu haben. Das heißt also... Ja, das ist schön, dass es es noch gibt. Aber man muss natürlich in jedem Fall...
Und wenn es Lancer MP3s sind?
Die hat man ja nicht auf seinem MP3-Player.
Ja, natürlich nicht. Das war aber bei MP3 doch sowieso, hat man doch oft.
Kenn ich aber auch Kopfhörer bei Fritz, bei dem man die Ohren kaputtführt.
Diese kleinen weißen, das sind diese kleinen weißen Kopfhörer, die wir den iPod-Usern abgenommen haben.
Ich denke aber gerade bei Videos auch, also wir kommen ja bald auch ins Zeitalter der mobilen Videoplayer und sind schon da, da ist es durchaus interessant auch, weil ein Film, wenn ich sozusagen Kino starte, also es ist ja immer so, ich sitze im Zug, gucke auf den Laptop, ich gucke auf den Film und dann kommt halt irgendwie der BGS durch, weil ich irgendwie gerade nach Holland fahre, und dann gucke ich drauf, Moment mal, der Film läuft doch aber erst nächste Woche hier in den Kinos an. Wo haben Sie den her? Dann bin ich natürlich in einer Erklärungsnot.
Warten Sie, das sage ich Ihnen, wenn ich meinen Rechner runtergefahren habe.
Mein Chef ist auch früher immer zum Mac-Laden gegangen mit seinem Notebook, wenn er schon ein neues Release drauf hatte, was es noch gar nicht gab.
Die Standardantwort von Frank müsste dann eigentlich sagen, ja wofür kennen Sie denn dann den Film schon?
Auch schön.
Ja.
Wir fassen, ich soll den Office Space Regler noch mal aufmachen. Dann mach ich noch mal den Office Space Regler auf. Wir fassen zusammen. Ich will verschlüsseln meine Daten, also die Daten auf meiner Festplatte. Was benutze ich, wenn ich Windows-User bin?
Ich würde empfehlen TrueCrypt zu nehmen. Ich hoffe, es gibt keine Leute, die da draußen Leute die negative Erfahrung damit gemacht haben. Wenn ihr das gemacht habt, dann schreibt uns, dann werden wir das nicht weiter empfehlen. Aber es ist ein Programm her, wo der Quellcode offen ist, das ist kostenlos. Es scheint zu funktionieren, es ist für meinen Geschmack, also schon einfach zu bedienen, also deutlich einfacher als mit anderen Programmen. Es ist nicht ganz so einfach wie die von Windows eingebaute Verschlüsselung. Die macht es mir aber sehr einfach, meine Daten nicht zu verschlüsseln oder falsch zu verschlüsseln.
Zerschlüsseln.
Und zumindestens von uns hier hat wohl niemand die Möglichkeit den Quellcode zu sehen dafür.
TrueCrypt für Windows.
Ja, DeviceMapper Crypto, DMCrypt ist das was man haben will.
Das klingt gleich auch schon viel liter als bei Windows.
Tatsächlich ein bisschen grandezer in sich. Und für Mac einfach das was das Betriebssystem mitliefert, Filevolt.
Ja, es gibt natürlich auch noch andere Tools, so als Freeware, da kann ich allerdings keine Aussage zu machen, aber bis jetzt gab es auch keine großen Bedenken gegen dieses Filevolt und nach den ersten Kinderkrankheiten scheint das Problem zu funktionieren, es sei denn der Strom wird spontan entnommen.
Meine Mails verschlüssel ich mit GNU-PG? Oder irgendwas anderem?
Also es gibt auch noch dieses PGP, die kommerzielle Variante, aber ja.
Also prinzipiell, wenn du Thunderbird benutzt, was dir sinnvollerweise tust für deine Mails, zumindest wenn du Windows hast.
Also auf Mac gibt es auch so ein Plugin für...
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es für Mail hab.
Also zumindest dafür gibt es ein GNU-PG Plugin und das funktioniert einfach auf Knopfdruck und fühlt sich gut an, es gut zu bedienen. Man sollte sich auf jeden Fall mal genau vorher durchlesen. Es gibt ganz einfache Anleitungen dafür und auch gut erklärt, wie das mit dieser Public Key Verschlüsselung funktioniert. Das heißt also, es ist nicht ganz einfach. Also wer das noch nie gemacht hat, für den ist es irgendwie schwer zu verstehen, dass ich einfach einen Schlüssel rausgeben kann, der einfach wirklich öffentlich ist, den jeder haben kann. Wie das dann funktioniert, dass es dann trotzdem noch sicher ist alles.
Ja und das GNU-PG selbst noch zu installieren ist natürlich auch noch ein kleiner...
Zumindest auf dem Mac.
Ja, den fand ich nicht. Also ich bin nun wirklich weit davon entfernt, Lead zu sein, aber ich fand das so schlimm nicht.
Ja wie gesagt, das Problem ist da die aktuellste Version. Also es gab letztens so eine Security oder ein Sicherheitsloch in GNU-PG und bei Mac sind sie da immer sehr langsam mit dem Installer-Programm das zu aktualisieren und wenn man da wirklich up-to-date sein will, dann sollte man das doch von Hand kompilieren.
Ich texte dich morgen mal an.
Super.
Das war Chaosradio 11.
Vielleicht noch eine ganz kurze Anekdote zum Mailverschluss. Der CCC hat nämlich gerade das Jahrhundertprojekt angegangen, um eine interne Mailingliste, sozusagen das Herzstück der internen Kommunikation, auf PGP, also verschlüsselte NUPG-Mails, umzustellen. Und es ist ein großartiges soziales Experiment. Da stehen jetzt Leute fest, die seit zehn Jahren im CCC sind. Pups, wie macht man das denn mit der Verschlüsselung? Was muss ich denn da einrichten? Dann kommen natürlich so die 200 Test-Mails auf der Liste. Mal mal gespannt, ob das klappt. Es ist natürlich auch total Unfug im Prinzip, eine Mailing-Liste mit mehreren hundert Personen da was zu verschlüsseln. Weil es gibt einfach de facto kein Vertrauen mehr und sowas. Aber es ist ein interessantes technisches Experiment. Und wenn wir sagen, okay, wir können es mit 400 Leuten, dann könnt ihr das mit eurer 10-Leute-Mailing-Liste auf jeden Fall auch.
Jetzt aber, das war Chaosradio 1911. Alles Wissenswerte steht auf chaosradio.ccc.de.
Ist gut jetzt.
Das war Chaosradio 1911. Alles Wissenswerte gibt es auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Den Podcast gibt es früher oder später dann auch im Netz beziehungsweise über iTunes unmittelbar zu beziehen. Wer Fragen hat, mailt an.
Mahlzeit.
Vielen Dank Frank, vielen Dank Harald, vielen Dank Huckel.
Und jetzt gucken wir das Miss Ostdeutschland-Video.
Miss Ostdeutschland-Video, genau das war's. Gute Nacht euch im Anschluss der Night Flight mit Martin Petersdorf.